hey it's evan carmichael and welcome to
season four of million dollar business
in this series i break down different
industries speak to experts who have
sold at least a million dollars in their
respective industries and ask them the
questions that you need to know so you
can copy and model their success we're
going to look at what it takes to sell 1
million plus books
i sit down for 10 episodes with neil
pastricha the new york times
best-selling author of six books which
have sold over 1 million copies and
spent over 200 weeks on bestseller lists
including the book of awesome the
happiness equation and how to get back
up his latest book on resilience is
called you are awesome and the link to
order it is in the description below
i'm gonna pick his brain and extract the
lessons that you need to help you sell
over a million books as well let's go
bring him in so my voice i think in my
writing is accessible
casual hopefully funny okay so i'm
trying to do casual and accessible and
when i look at books that have sold a
million copies yeah
most of them
are casual
and accessible
they are don't sweat small stuff they're
the monk who sold this ferrari
they are who moved my cheese they are
the one minute manager
right i could go on and on and on
bernie brown stuff daring greatly uh
if you keep looking at the books that
sell a
crapload it's because you get the tone
and therefore they appeal to a wider and
massive mass audience
welcome aboard man thank you for joining
us in evan
great to be here so you're going to
teach us how to sell a million books
this is this is a ten part series this
is episode one
and this one's about sharpening your
voice so yes what does that mean
well here's the funny thing about books
before we like so i'm i'm like i'm i'm
so all in on this series i'm super
excited to talk about selling a ton of
books because i take books
seriously yeah you love
youtube yeah i love books books books i
live in here i like spent all my time
there and i realized a few years ago and
i don't know if someone told me if it
just kind of hit me it's like when you
buy a book what are you really buying
essentially what you're buying
is a voice
in your head for a certain number of
hours okay so what you're buying when
you buy a book if you think about it is
you're just buying someone's company
in your brain in your mind in a
conversation for a set number of hours
therefore the number one thing you need
to do before we even talk about the
selling of the books is
sharpening your voice you have to have a
voice that people want to hang out with
that people want to
listen to that people want to be around
right most of the time when you're
talking to your friends or family
hopefully
they are engaged with you in
conversation but then when i when i ask
people can you translate that to your
writing the writing suddenly is it
becomes stiff it becomes formal it
sounds like wikipedia you open any
business book off a business bookshelf i
know a lot of your audience loves
business books it's like it's dry it's
boring it doesn't sound like the person
really sounds
in real life why is that
because what we do when we write is we
we formalize ourselves we feel like we
got to use big words and we have to use
semicolons no one talks with semicolons
have you ever said a semicolon that
doesn't exist in language but when you
write people are like yeah i gotta like
you know that's definitely half a
sentence you know semi skull semicolon
so the first thing you got to do is
sharpen your voice and people are like
well how
how do you do it how do you do that yeah
you know
uh
and uh and just the root of this issue
by the way is a great little little
story i heard about david foster wallace
so david foster wallace has sold
millions of books
he's no longer alive but wrote the book
infinite jest among other things and
while that book was being sold he also
was teaching
writing class at a college and so the
way he would open his classes he would
say
um
well the good news for all of you is
we're going to learn how to write
and really all writing is
is talking
so
if you can talk
you can write you can write
and everyone's like breathe a sigh of
relief we're in class with david foster
walls it's going to be a piece of cake
and then he says but how many people do
you know that can really talk
that can really talk he's like not that
many people so let's work on your voice
on how you speak and how you think and
then it translates into writing
the number one thing you can do to
sharpen your voice is to read
fiction
daily wow okay i read zero fiction so
this is very interesting okay keep going
the number one thing you can do to
sharpen your voice is to read
fiction daily
it should be fiction specifically
because fiction is largely in another
voice
you might be a 13 year old girl in south
africa you might be the boy a boy in a
boat you might be margaret talking to
god right are you there god it's me
margaret you take on the internal
mental monologue of a character who
isn't you
who maybe not the same gender as you the
same culture as you the same language
your background as you and you submerse
your own mind in someone else's
voice
some writers are better at this than
others my favorite book
over anything else
to practice
voice is a book called cloud atlas okay
by david mitchell
um it was turned into a famous movie
with with tom hanks and and was directed
by the welkowski's
uh of the matrix okay i don't know if
you know this movie it seems same title
cloud atlas clogged cloud outlet have
you seen this movie okay okay so i think
it was like a box office like
okay unfortunately it's like a huge
giant big budget movie i saw it at the
film festival okay and i loved it and in
terms of this book the book is written
like a book that keeps opening up deeper
and deeper and deeper over hundreds and
hundreds of years and every time it
opens up it changes voice completely
so you will realize like like i did is
like wait a minute one author has
written this book
under the guise of six different
characters
if that's too hard or too literary
because it kind of is almost even for me
i'm like oh man this is like hard to get
my under on start with like the
babysitter's club
do you remember the babysitter's club so
300 million copies it's a book series
when i was a kid my sister had them all
and it would be like christy's big idea
a book
written by presumably christy right then
it was like claudia's giant adventures
the book written by claudia and then
they had these books every like 10 books
called the treasuries where all the
girls go to disney world and every
chapter of the book is written by a
different character okay so you start
learning about voice how one
author
can work in a number of different voices
and so is the idea that i'm trying all
these different things to say huh this
part really resonates with me yeah and
then you that helps you identify what
your voice well you start shaking
yourself loose a little bit okay right
the goal here ultimately is to get how
you speak practice how you speaking how
have you have you speak in a captivating
way and have that translate directly to
the page but i recommend reading fiction
because it expands what your awareness
is a voice in writing so speaking of
voices like like take a book like here i
brought it with me uh the help okay
catherine stockett this is a debut novel
okay that's sold it doesn't say on the
front but i know it sold at least three
million copies if i read the first the
first chapter of the first page it just
says
may mobley was born on an early sunday
morning in august 1960 a church baby we
like to call it taking care of white
babies that's what i do along with all
the cooking and the cleaning i done
raised 17 kids in my lifetime i know how
to get them babies to sleep stop crying
and go in the toilet bowl before they
mamas even get out of bed in the morning
yeah
you can hear it yeah what a powerful
voice
and that is
you and your brain sifting into another
character's way of thinking right the
goal here though is to sharpen your own
voice right so first thing to do is
expose yourself to fiction because it's
going to keep stirring up ideas and
thoughts and you see that and like the
word ah there was like a done at you
know it's written that way you you start
being more comfortable with your own
style of writing okay second thing you
need to do here is uh dictate and
transcribe
okay okay so
when you're in a car
when you're walking in the street when
you get an idea
don't say oh i want to write an article
about
selling a million books
literally try it to hit record and say
okay first thing on sell a million books
is sharpen your voice i think i think
everyone should read more fiction uh i
i'm i'm recording it and then i get home
i transcribe my own speaking okay and
when i read that writing it sounds
different than if i wrote it right what
you're then doing is practicing your
voice as it's coming from your brain to
your mouth now to your fingers and you
aren't interrupting that flow because
you're thinking how do i write you're
literally writing down what you said
okay
totally different right it's it's more
conversational completely yeah and
that's essentially what people want when
they buy a book oh wow what about people
it's so interesting so i think about
people who are writing books typically a
lot of them are not great speakers
zombie would much rather
just sit and write than than be a
speaker and stay in front of a stage and
and so you're saying
no you need to practice maybe not being
in front of a stage but you have to
practice
it's speaking out well i should say when
you dictate and transcribe your own
writing when you read it you're gonna
you're gonna cringe right you're gonna
be like oh my gosh like
that horrible grammar i have you know
you're gonna read that and you're gonna
be like whoa this is
doesn't sound
correct but as you edit that the root
kind of
middle of it the skeleton of that thing
will stay more conversational more
casual and most importantly more
accessible to people reading it if it
starts with a transcription
so
i don't think it's important to like
speak perfectly right i certainly don't
you can hear i'm speaking i'm all over
the place but but i'm gonna get you but
you're gonna be you're gonna edit it
down right like well yeah exactly okay
right and and
and that's what i'm saying is when you
read your own
dictation and transcription you
recognize all kinds of thinking patterns
that you were unfortunately already
editing out when you started writing
and the goal of sharpening your voice is
when people buy a book they're really
buying a voice that voice has to be
accessible to them
it can't be
so high and mighty and so academic and
so full of big words and so full of tall
strong pros that people
can't reach it
okay
so i admit that most of my
recommendations are biased towards
non-fiction because that's the category
that i'm in although i'm trying to use
fiction as examples because narrative
voice is what sells right my editor on
the book of awesome and some of my
sequels is one by the name of amy
einhorn she's one of the most successful
editors ever in publishing something
like a forty percent hit rate on the new
york times bestseller list nice the help
is also one of her books there's many
books that amy einhorn has edited when
people look at amy einhorn the editor
and they say
how do you choose your books you get a
thousand books a minute to a year you
only print ten of them making up the
numbers but let's just say for her
magnitude she's like all i'm looking for
is one thing
voice
that's it
i don't care if it's fiction i don't
care if it's non-fiction i don't care
who it's targeted to
if i can hear that voice in that book
i buy the book
and when i first talked to amy before
the book of awesome came out that's my
first book in 2010. she told me i only
have one other book
uh under my imprint and it's a book
called the help it's not out yet so the
help was the first book the [ __ ] of
austin was the second nice and they both
stole millions of copies because she's
only looking for one thing she's only
looking for voice and so we're going to
talk as this segment goes on and we talk
about there's 10 things we're going to
talk about a lot more things about
selling a million books but the first
thing that matters more than anything
else is voice
okay
in the nonfiction world there's a great
book called the coaching habit by
michael bungay stanier
also brought it with me i can grab it if
you want
and similarly when you read the book you
hear him
talking to you
so of course it's like you're hanging
out with somebody
of course you're more likely to read it
therefore recommend it buy it buy
multiple copies because you had a
connection with the book
how else do you get your voice to be
strong yep
journaling okay
okay so everybody knows you should be
journaling there's so much science and
research out there about it professor
slater and penna baker did a famous
study that shows that if you journal for
just 20 minutes a day
then you're 50 more likely to stay
together in your romantic relationship
after three months that's a crazy study
wow okay
both people's journaling or just one the
couple couple together it's done at the
university of texas i always joking on
stage like three months is a really long
relationship right at the university of
texas everyone laughs i say i say but
that's in any college or university
campus
sean acor positive psychology researcher
has also done a journaling study on
patients with chronic neuromuscular pain
if those patients can journal for six
weeks
you can reduce their pain medication by
up to 50 percent at the six month mark
so you and i have probably heard lots of
these studies and we're like oh yeah
journaling's good for you
but what i'm arguing today is it's
actually also very very good for your
voice okay
okay
most people have a challenge with
journaling you know what the challenge
is what i write about
that what do i write about and i just
don't do it like it's just like it's
just like eating healthy or like going
and exercising it's like yeah i heard
that's good yeah
i can't just get into like a rhythm like
that kind of piece of cake so what i do
in my life to force more journaling
therefore force more unfiltered writing
and unfiltered thinking which helps my
voice is i surround myself in journals
okay i do it three ways number one i
have a journal okay that helps um but i
i started this process on a cue card and
now i do it in a journal it's called two
minute mornings so every morning when i
wake up i fill this out it's just three
prompts okay i will let go of
i am grateful for i will focus on
each of these things is backed by a
specific scientific study that shows
that it helps process your anxieties and
help your mind focus on the positives
every morning every morning it's a
two-minute practice i do it every day
you can do it on a cue card i made a
book just to make sure i can actually do
it yep
second thing i subscribe to a website
called ah life.com okay
a-h-h-l-i-f-e dot com okay when you
subscribe to all life.com which by the
way is totally free
it asks you how frequently would you
like to journal i said every monday
wednesday and friday at 9 00 pm that's
what i said so on those days it spits
out an email to me saying
how was your day
and don't forget three weeks ago or
seven months ago you said this right so
you see one of your old entries all you
do is reply to the email with what's
inside your brain or mind at the time
okay it's a private way because it's
through an email service but free to
just get some anxieties or thoughts out
the third thing i do and this is a model
i stole from derek sivers it was a great
article on journaling on his website
sivirs.org
is i keep a word document
on my computer
which is just called j i just call it j
for journaling okay whenever i'm
wrestling with something which is pretty
often i just open it up and i just start
flow of consciousness
like i'm really stressed about x here's
why here's what i think here's what i'm
assuming to be wrong and by the time i'm
done
you always feel better because i've just
written 500 words to process the anxiety
inside me it's not stewing around
anymore by surrounding myself with
journals i am a journaling right that's
the first thing but b
constantly sharpening my voice because
i'm writing so much stuff that no one
sees
right
journaling in the morning i've got an
email subscription and i've got this
word document thing that's three
journaling things i've got
all in the name of helping my mind but
also constantly sharpening my voice
could you define your voice yeah what's
a voice mean no no like for you what is
your voice oh okay so my voice i think
in my writing is accessible
casual hopefully funny you know it's
like i'm talking to you let's see like a
little bit light-hearted uh i might
approach things from different angles
and i come at them i i made fun of
semicolons earlier i got no semicolons
in any of my books ever like super
important to me because like you're
anticipating well kurt vonnegut has a
quote saying semicolons are like uh
all semicolons do show you went to
college okay you know he's like he has a
terrible phrase about them but he's like
making fun of the fact okay that like we
use them to be sound impressive yeah
okay so i'm trying to do casual and
accessible and when i look at books that
have sold a million copies yeah
most of them
are casual
and accessible
they are don't sweat the small stuff
they're the monk who sold this ferrari
they are who moved my cheese they are
the one minute manager
right i can go on and on and on
bernie brown stuff daring greatly uh
if you keep looking at the books that
sell a
crapload it's because you get the tone
and therefore they appeal to a wider and
master mass audience and even smart
people yeah
prefer accessible books yeah they might
buy the thick giant
academic dense thing but they don't get
through it enough that they're gonna buy
it and recommend to other people a lot
of those big thick smart books are just
collecting dust on everyone's bookshelf
do you then use that so if you know you
want them to be accessible you want to
be humorous uh conversational yeah do
you then use that as a filter through
your editing to say okay let me read
that chapter that i wrote back and say
hmm
it didn't hit these three things so i
need to i need to fix it yeah i'm also
like my my rece my most recent book you
are awesome
we did seven edits on that that means
the entire 300 page book i read through
and changed tremendously seven times
over two years so constantly constantly
constantly trying to make it as simple
clean crisp and accessible as possible
there should never be a point in the
writing where the reader is thinking how
they just jump from that to that
it's really really really kind of simple
clean crisp
voice as best as i can do it and and the
reader needs to feel like they're
sitting down like this yeah like we are
having a conversation with that's why
your channel's so big and why your
content is exploding and why youtube is
exploding in general is because it's a
pretty close way to connect with
someone's voice books are trying to jump
and i would argue books are still the
densest form of compressed knowledge we
have in the world like in a 300 page
book you might get 20 years of someone's
research explained in the cleanest
christmas way possible so it's an
amazing way to get stuff faster and i
personally read faster than i watch
that's just you know like on a ted talk
i'll like read the transcript okay
because it takes two minutes instead of
18. right you know what i'm saying this
is you're a fast reader well but it's
like a quick read yeah
and like that's why people probably
listen i'm like yeah people are probably
watching this right now in like 1.5 yeah
this guy's too slow speed i'm up for
let's go yeah would it is this fair
maybe i don't know why i'm thinking of
this uh non-fiction is imagine them
having a conversation yeah like this
with the author yes and fiction is i'm
watching the conversation between two
people
totally and it depends how the fiction
is written so sometimes the fiction's
written in third person right to your
point there's a there's a um a narrator
kind of overseeing the story yeah
sometimes it's written in first person
i woke up on my 13th birthday and my mom
said to me you know then you're in the
person's mind there's some books and one
i really recommend is called how to get
filthy rich in rising asia by mohsin
hamad it's written in second person
second person is amazing so it's like
choose your own adventure it's like you
open your eyes you're under the bed you
see your mom you you know the whole
books written like that
so there's ways that you can use voice
to grip people as well and if you can do
something unique or interesting like a
second person story or
getting a voice or review that people
the help you know it's like
you can hear in that something that you
wouldn't otherwise hear and it's a
beautiful thing to listen to and it
needs to be captured in the first you
got a couple pages well exactly and it
has to be the same voice for the whole
book right but as i open it up and maybe
it's an assignment for people to go home
and do go look at any of your books or
these books you talked about and just go
read the first three pages
exactly and you can probably capture
what their voice is and then go look at
your book in the first three pages and
if it's just
introduction or you know super boring
because okay i can i can i can tell that
these guys have a voice and i need to
sharpen my own so in this book you were
awesome um and i did the same for the
happiness equation
um
the opening of any book
is 10 pages that you as the author do
not get to control
so if you open this book
okay there's 10 pages that you don't get
to control they're like blurbs right
right people saying nice things about
your book tony robbins says neil is the
main yeah right right then there's like
a title there's like a title page then
there's like a copyright page yeah then
there's like table of contents and the
table contest keeps going yeah that so
so it's like they're so far into this
thing before they hear your voice yeah
so
with all my books what i try to do is
capture my voice a bit early in this
book if you if you open the flap i've
hidden a phrase it's in my voice
it is in you under the jacket i also
wrote a thing that's right at the front
i skipped over called three ways to get
the most out of this book okay so you
hear my voice quickly in this book the
first thing you see when you open it is
uh
uh
you are what you eat
and you are what you read
are you hungry let's go and that's the
first thing you see when you open this
book i love it because i want people to
hear the voice before they have to go
through the 10 pages of hurdling of all
this cool library of congress copyright
title pages that stuff's super boring so
you want people to grab you and i stole
that idea by the way from another birth
that sold millions of copies called how
to win friends and influence people by
dale carnegie when you open that book it
says seven things you're going to learn
in this book and you hear him talking to
you before you have to go through all
the rigmarole
how do you bridge the connection between
you and the reader quick you said first
sentence i'd say even when you open the
book
and i i even argue this is a weird thing
but i don't i don't agree with
dedications in books
every book has a dedication none of mine
do
because i think that when you pay 30
from a bookstore to buy a book and you
get home i don't want it to say to cindy
i love you right you're like who's cindy
that's not to me so i and to the reader
to me feels disingenuous so i've got no
dedications in my book they're at the
back and the acknowledgements so that i
can continue to connect the reader to
the voice without any interruption or
interference cool i love it just a
personal bias i love everyone who's an
author will hate this because they're
like what's he saying about my dad i
love cindy
cindy's my wife
gotta leave her in
i love it so so rule number one you have
to find your voice sharpen that voice
too open your voice yeah cool today
we're talking about how to find your
fans
what do you got well here's the thing
it used to be for 200 000 years since
our species has been around that if you
wrote the damn book
then you found your fans you put the
book out there in the first place you
coagulated all your thoughts for
dozens of years of life and you put them
down to like this big important text and
you released it to the market the
breathless fans would then come they
come after but the world's completely
backwards now evan you know this we're
surrounded we're doused in information
we've got too much content you know
you've all know harare the guy who wrote
sapien says it used to be information
was power now clarity is power
right so in this endless sea of free
content everywhere it's no longer enough
to write a book to find fans because a
million of books come out a year a
million books got published a year 500
000 from the big five publishers another
500 000 self-published and i didn't make
those numbers up those are like
legitimately a million books are
published here so if you just write a
book
you're one in a million
you're one in a million i would wager
maybe 50 of those sell a million copies
so you have no chance you have no chance
of of making that dent that you want to
the only way
around that is to find your fans
first
give to them endlessly
for a period of years
content that they love that they want to
share that they're proud to be
affiliated with that they want to wear
the t-shirt for
then only then say oh and now i have a
book
okay there's a guy who did this uh for
the last few years you might have heard
of him here i brought his book for you
subtle art not giving by mark manson
come on this guy markmanson.net gave
endlessly for years he wrote these
incredible articles about love and
relationships and
you know purpose and meaning and so when
two years later he said oh by the way
now i'm going to do a book boom he sold
9 million copies of this thing it's
crazy and counting another guy that does
this really well
friend of the channel friend of the
channel
of the channel holiday brian hallway
this guy gives so much he writes
probably i would have to guess 75 of his
writing is not in the book it's his
monthly book club list it's his regular
articles on medium he's constantly
giving free content everywhere so when
once in a while he says oh by the way
i've got a book people line up for it
and it pops quick sold over a million
books another guy who does this really
well these are people like i show up the
books to give people models they can
google them why just take it from me
learn from austin cleon
former reference librarian
lives down in austin texas runs an
incredible friday email list where he
just gives 10 pieces of interesting art
he finds every year in addition to that
he's got a regular blog with all this
content so when he finally puts out a
book you're like yeah i'll i'd like what
that guy says in fact he found the fans
on this post first this was a post
called steal like an artist and the post
went so viral that it then turned into a
book okay
find your fans first
there it is this is my first book
it's called the book of awesome
in 2008 this came out in 2010 let me
tell you about 2008 2008 i went through
the worst year of my life
lost a marriage and lost a friend and i
won't go through a ton of details
there's a whole ted talk just on those
two things but now we're 10 years later
i'll just say i was the worst year of my
life
what did i do
i started writing a blog called
1000awesomethings.com to try to cheer
myself up no one reads this thing except
for my mom she sends it to my dad my
traffic doubles okay i'm talking nobody
raised this thing right a month into it
i wrote a post number 980 it's a
thousand
started from a countdown okay that's
like 20 posts
number 980 old dangerous playground
equipment
okay
as i do every day i post an essay about
it i got pictures i got comments down
there below i reply to the comments this
one hits the front page of farc.com so i
might go from 50 hits a day on my
website that no one reads to 50 000. wow
that's from that one hit
okay then it starts making of course
wire magazine and reddit and they'll
feed off each other
so by the time the book of austin came
out i had 10 million people
who had visited or read my website
so then
it's no surprise maybe that in that
first week we sold maybe 5 000 copies
it doesn't sound like much but was
enough to make number two on the
bestseller list when you make number two
on the bestseller list all the
bookstores and people read the
bestsellers they're like oh well that's
a book that i should buy it's on the
bestseller list they featured at the
front of the stores that creates its own
positive stickiness and now we hit
number one the next week and it stayed
at number one for over a hundred
straight weeks that's crazy it's crazy
but it's because i found the fans first
and then i gave them a book and remember
i said the website of like 10 million
hits at the time of the book publishing
now it's closer to 100 million but the
time is 10 million and i told you in the
first week i only sold 5 000 books right
a very very very small percentage of my
audience bought the book in the first
week
but it was enough
when a normal book would sell 50 copies
a week
to just pop onto the best house that
created a positive churn
only worked because i found the fans
first did you
try to
like in your head was it i want to be an
author or are you just starting the vlog
well it's it's a hard question for me to
answer because as a child i was super
quiet super introverted had very few
friends and writing was a place for me i
wrote for my little town newspaper i was
the editor of my portable six press in
grade six i
started the newspaper in high school i
was the editor of my college newspaper
so writing was always a natural home i
stopped writing for 10 years but when i
went through the divorce when i lost my
friend
i turned back to writing just because it
gave me some salvation so did i always
want to be a writer uh i mean it was
maybe a dream in the back of my head
that i didn't quite admit to myself
because i thought it was so implausible
but it was a safe space for me right so
i was sharpening my voice right for many
years to get to the place where i
started my blog and before that blog i
should also mention for years
since i was like 10 15 20 years younger
i had many failed blogs okay on the way
there and there's a chance that one
might have failed but then maybe a year
or two later i would have started a new
one you got to find the fans first and
if you don't have the fans
you know they probably aren't going to
buy your book who's going to buy it from
the beginning even a book like the
martian
right or twilight these are big fiction
books that have sold multiple millions
of copies they found their fans online
first
both serialized both released for free
online get tons of fans and traction on
the web different websites then the
martian comes out then twilight comes
out people were like ready to buy it
because
twilight was
was slash fiction it was like a
sexualized harry potter fiction i
believe
and the martian andy weir had written a
tiny little short story that went viral
then he started releasing chapters of
the martian boom then comes in the book
so find the fans first the world has
changed it is too loud and too cluttered
to try anything else what what frequency
should we put now it's like somebody
wants to read a book they want it to be
a bestseller
how often should they be releasing
written content on
social media or websites i'll use a
great example to answer this question uh
there's a guy by the name of brent
stanson i think i'm saying his name
right he created um a concept called
humans of new york yeah and when you
hear him interviewed he said well i
first tried architecture in chicago or
like
like skyscrapers of detroit like he
literally had other
ideas and then he bumped into one that
got traction called humans of new york
i don't think he was posting daily at
the time but it was a photo of somebody
with a captivatingly well-written little
write-up of the person a quote you could
hear his voice in it
okay
build traction found fans got a
following
when you find a following when you find
fans you then increase your frequency
right he probably then started posting
daily at that time and i don't want to
speak for him because i don't know him
personally but i'm just saying then you
ramp up your content to deliver what
people frothing at the mouth for boom
the book comes out humans of new york
it's a home run right out of the gate
new york times best seller stays there
for weeks and weeks and weeks
because he had fans first
and the way to find these fans by the
way is one to sharpen your voice we
already talked about that but two it's
to be incredibly philanthropic
okay
what do you mean give
give
give give
give that's what you do
that's why you got two million
subscribers right
when i come to your channel i'm just
giving free stuff
i'm giving 10 ways to learn from steve
jobs i'm giving i'm giving so much
content so that when it's time for like
evan to be like hey bought my buck i'm
like of course
we have a natural reciprocity baked into
our psyches it's the root of the book
the seminal book called influence by
robert cialdini i'm trying to only
reference books that have sold over a
million copies that one definitely has
but when we are given stuff for long
periods of time we want to give back
okay we want to so so what am i giving
as an author content for free online so
markmanson.net
is a has no ads
right
he's not tracking you
he's not trying to sell you anything you
just get free content
and then when the subtle art not giving
a [ __ ] comes out which is his book
you're like oh
i have been reading that guy's content
some people like tim ferriss even go so
far as to say hey if you like any of my
thousand free blog posts right my 500
free podcast right like they actually
like list out all the stuff then would
you buy my book yeah and humans are like
yeah like
i'll drop 20 for the guy's book and it's
those people who then read it love it
and tell the others who have no idea who
the guy is
or buy it from christmas presents
because
number of copies of the book of awesome
sold
uh subtract the number of people that
have read my blog
most people that have the book never
even heard of the blog right they were
just given to them by someone else who
had or had or had or had root root room
you had your super fans you got to have
the super fans find your fans first
what kind of ramp up do you think
somebody should like if people are
watching this they want to have their
own best-selling book right what's the
ramp up in terms of giving free content
away
is it six months i mean for years two
years of doing that yeah this is a hard
question answered partly because it's
like
there is no perfect answer some people's
stuff takes off right away some people
grind for years and then they have
something kind of explode uh and you
never know when to quit okay so part of
the problem of course when you're
putting out free content and you're
trying to find fans is
well i'm not getting any fans that's the
normal reaction right
so when do i stop
remember i said before thousands of
things.com i had numbers tons of blogs
that never worked over the years they're
my teens throughout my 20s right like
never worked
and there's a role model of mine
uh he doesn't know that he's my role
model but his name is todd hansen okay
he was one of the original editors
of a comedy newspaper called the onion
okay turn into the onion.com okay he was
interviewed by a guy named mike sachs in
a book called and here's the kicker and
he was asked hey
how do i write comedy for money like you
and he said everyone asked me that
question i'll go on panels at colleges
i'll take q a people are like hey i'm
funny right
how do i get paid for being funny and
his answer
is the best
he says
do it for free for 10 years
then it'll probably take off okay
because what have you been doing for 10
years sharpening your voice constantly
getting better you're not going to get
worse by keep doing it and he did it for
free for 10 years and if you look at me
with the book of awesome you can say oh
yeah neil it took a month to get that
hit actually evan it took 20 years right
because i've been writing since i was
six years old then the high school
newspaper then the college newspaper
then all these blogs that didn't work
some of which i like put money into or
and some of which i really tried to make
work some
nothing until that pop
my mom would say yeah cause you've been
working on it for 20 years if it's not
timing and i mean yes it's it's it's
having the right luck and the
circumstances and how good are you we're
going to get to luck later there's a lot
of luck for sure okay yeah um
if it's not timing then is it is it
numbers like whether it's 1 000 true
friends or like how do i know okay
here's the test here's the test here's
the test this is a test okay
do you know how i knew there's two
indicators that i knew that this thing
was going to take off okay before the
book before the blog even had like 10
hits 10 or 10 uh posts okay and they
were this
and i've done this on every blog and
it's the only blog where i got this
indicator number one i emailed it to
everybody i knew
like from my gmail account like
so i can still remember subject line was
honest to blog
and this it said dear everyone i know
comma
i just started a blog
can you please check it out yeah
www.1000awesomethings.com
let me know what you think neil that's
it short sweet to the point
i knew i sent that to like 100 people
and so i could watch the hit counter on
my vlog
over the next day or two i got 700 hits
so what i thought was not only are they
forwarding it to people but those people
who i don't know
are forwarding it to others
so i had a multiple of hits
compared to the number of people i sent
you that was big the second big
indicator was i got a comment
on my blog
from a stranger
you've made it i was like who's this
person who's joe 28 i don't know any
jokes right and that was so crucial for
me because i was like what a cool little
indicator someone who doesn't know me
is hanging out here
i know those two things sound so tiny
and small but you have to remember for
all these other projects i had before
this one i never had that i sent it to
100 people 50 check it out and the next
day it's 25 and four days later no one
like it didn't have the natural
shareability
that's the only way anything gets
transferred people have to be willing to
share of their own volition
why would they do that because it says
something about who they are
it speaks to their own identity
a great website is called weight but
y.com written by tim urban tim's a
friend of mine
and his website has legions
of super fans
because when i for one of tim's articles
which is usually like a 10 000 word
essay about artificial intelligence what
i'm really saying is i'm smart
i understand this i think you'd unders i
think you'd understand and enjoy this
too so there's an identity thing that
happens as people share maybe when
people share my blog they're saying i'm
funny or i'm focused on the positive i'm
an optimistic person there's something
about their identity that they're saying
to others
when they share it
i think that's important to to talk
about because you're only going to share
stuff you love
and you're only going to share stuff if
it reflects positively on you
i think about my youtube channel and i
want i've been around for 10 years on
youtube yeah
it took me five years to get to seven
thousand subscribers
right and then five years to go from
seven thousand to two that bodes well
for me i'm a year in i got like a
hundred people on my thing i'm like
still waiting for a comment from someone
i don't know
i said i would go do it for you but i
know you
um but i mean i guess with a lot of
people in in the early stages of
creation yeah i wasn't taking it
seriously i was just throwing out my
content every now and then i wasn't part
of the plan and so i
i like that as an asset test of hey
create some content share with your
friends and see does it get more views
than the number of people you sent it to
as a quick asset test to say this is
something i might take off or not and
bid into the asset test don't ask them
to share it hmm
just say tell me what you think
because then you'll see if they
naturally share it right not don't burn
your goodwill by ask them to forward it
because they don't want to people feel
icky right just send it to them and
watch see what they do
do you still have that first email i do
yeah you want me to dig it up for this i
can find it yeah we should put it we'll
put it we should put it in the
description sure i'll see if i can find
it yeah i'm pretty sure i can that'd be
pretty i've had the same email address
for a long time that'd be pretty cool
yeah cool so so before you go off and
get the book deal you have to find your
fans you have to find your fans one last
little tip though yeah this is a
personal bias i'm just gonna throw it in
there for anyone who's thinking about
like what do i do what do i launch is
focus on the positive
just focus on the positive
that's what's in short supply
99 of the content out there known as the
news the radio the television
is negative
because our brains are naturally
oriented towards looking for negative
things it's an evolutionary program
inside of us all helps us stay alive
it's helped us survive for hundreds of
thousands of years that's why on a
newspaper if it bleeds it leads
the world is oriented to give you bad
news and they will never stop because
we're naturally programmed so you know
what's in short supply
content on your channel
positive stuff
helping people feel better about where
they are and just getting a little bit
improved
there's a reason self-help is the
biggest category in the bookstore
because that's what's in short supply
nobody makes a buck selling good news
so you can be that person
i love it we're talking about
breathability equals read ability
what do you got
man breathability does equal readability
i was reading a great book a number of
years ago called on writing by stephen
king okay and he has this great point in
the middle of the book you were the one
that first told me that like yeah and
sometimes like way deep in the middle of
a video or the book like there's the
best point for me yeah the best part
about the book was in the middle he said
you ever go to a bookstore
and you see someone do this
yeah
yeah for years i was always like why do
people do that there really is no it
doesn't and if you ask someone why did
you do that they don't actually have an
answer they're not like oh i'm looking
for this or i'm looking for that
but actually he's like they're checking
the breathability of it okay how much
air a book has
because there's a difference between a
book that is light
fluffy
easy to read
has air in it is breathable then a book
that is
tight
dense no pictures no graphics right no
headlines
oh
right
now i like both books
you probably do too
maybe on both of our books we have both
kinds of books the airy ones and the
thick dense ones
interestingly the books might be the
exact same dimensions they might be the
exact same thickness
but one of them i have 50 000 words in
them the other one might have 400 000
words in them right infinite jess by
david foster walls a 1200 page book i
counted the words like i just did like
math of like you know i measured one
page and we'll play with it not one at a
time no no but it's like it's like 500
000 words that's crazy okay whereas
the happiness equation by me
this book
big thick card cover yeah is like
50 to 60 000 words yeah but when you
open it
guess what yeah there's lots of little
stories there's headlines there's a
dilbert cartoon right there's like
little there's little there's like lots
of i call them scribbles like there's
little boxes there's drawings i want
people to feel like the book is
breathable because breathability equals
readability it does it does you are much
more likely to read a book that you can
get through
so i was thinking about that as i look
at my books i was like other books on my
bookshelf have sold millions of books
i'm like oh
this book has sold
potentially billions like this is like
one of the most popular business books
of all time who've moved my cheese so i
i opened it up first thing you notice is
okay oh yeah it says right in the back
over 24 million copies
okay you should get this guy on
boot me off no this is great okay okay
good value okay so this this guy first
of all it's less than 100 pages that's
crazy so the first thing you notice is
okay i can get through this yeah check
out the spine yeah it's like super thin
yeah then uh it's written in like 20.
font yep there's pictures in it
if you do not change you can become
extinct like that's the whole thing yeah
this book is look at oh there's so many
cheese pictures
okay so i'm like who do i know
contemporary writers today that are
doing this um i have a good friend
uh he's on his way to selling a million
copies of this i think he's at half a
million his name is michael bungay
stanier it's called the coaching habit
when i asked him about editing he said
you know i found a great editor also
happened to be seth godin's editor seth
godin very much known for his
breathability yeah short simple prose
right
and he got he whittled this book down to
25 000 words you could argue that's the
same as an epic blog post in someone's
blog yeah but look at the breathability
look at look at the big huge questions
like
huge font like
there's a reason why this thing has been
hanging out in the top 1000 on amazon
for four years
it's because it's super breathable
they're for readable therefore only then
you get to shareable tell people
aboutable buy copies for your
friendsable because you have to read it
too
right how much of that is done by the
author versus the publisher well here's
the thing that's related to this
question is
what the thing i'm talking about is
super hard
people think oh he's saying like don't
put much in it he's like no no no no no
no it's harder to make it breathable
than
not the there's an old famous mark twain
quote uh sorry my letter was so long i
didn't have time to make it short right
right the idea is no the editing the
whittling the simplification the
clarification the cutting cutting
cutting cutting cutting to the bone
that is what takes you edit after edit
after edit sure the book of awesome is
actually just 200 blog posts from a
thousand awesome things.com but we
edited this thing over a year try to
make it like simple short look at this
one blowing up the candles on your first
try keep the spit to yourself and just
let it fly it's time to get windy
awesome done
like then you go to the next one like
sneaking mcdonald's and hiding the
evidence your family so that one's a bit
longer i also put lots of bold i
highlighted words in bold for no reason
other than that's how it was in mad
magazine and archie comics when i was a
kid
those are those are tailored towards
children with attention problems like me
and so add in some pictures i hired a
photographer you know
that little joke people say when they
open them up like oh no pictures
there's no pictures in that no drawings
they're right there should
every book should have some arts or some
way to visually stimulate and challenge
the reader because otherwise
it's gonna collect dust
not many of us have a 14 hour flight to
really sink into gun germs and steel
right right and that book has done well
but the number of people who have read
it would be less than some of the books
i'm referring to
24 million copies of who moved my cheese
so the book's 96 pages right you know
so so again is that is that something
that you as the author
think about and say okay how do i make
this more breathable or is that here's
my finished manuscript publisher
editing
yeah so it depends on your relationship
with your publisher and editor in my
case historically i've had to
sometimes convince them
right wow yeah because
people want to put out a book that's
full
that's stuffed to the brim
and on my new book so i'll tell you some
of the conversations because we're
recording this before this book comes
out yeah okay so when you were awesome i
said to them hey when you open the front
page can i put this little
secret note
so you open the book you hear the voice
it says um
you are what you eat and you are what
you read are you hungry let's go so
they're like oh okay we can do that then
i'm like oh and when you peel open the
the cover of the book can we hide a
little message underneath the flap yeah
and they're like
yeah okay we'll we'll do that that's
nice well sure so i'm and i'm like oh
can we insert the graphic of i have this
story about the ellipses the dot dot dot
one of my models from this book is about
adding an ellipses to your life whenever
you hit a dead end
so i found the history of the ellipses i
found the first ever time it was used in
history 500 years ago i got an image of
it obviously it's not a copyright it's
500 years old i put it in the book and
they said oh we don't need that picture
that's not needed i was like i know it's
not needed
but i want it for breathability
so later in the book i'm talking about
postsecret.com the guy frank warren he's
collected over a million postcards it's
the largest advertisement free blog in
the world and i said let's put some of
the postcards in the book they said i
don't know if it's needed but to their
credit when i said but i want it for
breathability i want pictures i want
something light they're like okay
handwritten really helps if you can
handwrite anything we live in an age
where everything we read is digital and
computer generated so now actually
handwrit handwriting stands out real
handwriting not computer handwriting
font i mean i have at the end of every
secret of this book the happiness
equation that's why for that exact
reason
that's all written by so i usually use a
sharper and printer paper for this
uh but at the end of every chapter if i
can find a chapter end really quick
come on neil don't fail me now here we
go there it is it's like i summarize the
lessons in my own
handwriting right cool so that way it's
like a signpost it adds to breathability
right it creates a little tone between
chapters so do you write the whole book
first yeah and then you think how do i
make this more be the best your word
document or script or file or whatever
you're using to write will not be
breathable got it
adding breathability into in
that's what i'm talking about every what
every how many pages well i love your
brain you're so you want to get it to
like
algorithm make it an algorithm like
every
i'll tell you the test yeah the grandma
test the grandma testing here's what you
do to answer that question you give the
book to your grandma
you leave it there on her counter table
on her bedside
and a month later
all you do is ask her one question what
page did you get up to
and i do this with my friends with my
books
i want to know where you stopped
i don't expect you to get through the
whole book how many books does the
average person get through i just want
to know where you stopped reading
because that tells me that i wasn't
enough to keep you flipping
right and on many of my books especially
in rough draft people are like oh page
50
page 100. so i go through my own book
yeah and i'm like what exactly is
happening oh page 50. no pictures from
page 30 onwards that'll do it
the chapter was too long
it kept going and going oh i didn't have
a enough of a nugget here so i'm always
trying to get people to flip you know
what the scarcest resource of all is
today in the world
time
attention
so breathability also helps because it
gives you a quicker path through it it's
partly why i think we're seeing the rise
of thin books are coming back
you know the ted talk books right peter
thiel's book zero to one you know you're
seeing a lot more of these like uh the
the the commencement speech books
are getting popular it's like that's a
commencement speech that's literally
like a 50-page book
but sells a lot of copies because i can
read it
it's breathable i can get through it
in the venture capital business that i
was in before
we had a grandmother test
as well which is similar in that the
executive summary is the first three
pages of your business plan typically
yeah and it's can your grandmother
understand exactly can they understand
the business that you're in yes if not
then we wouldn't read the rest of the
business plan i mean that's exactly the
same principle the root of it is is it
simple breathability readability and the
three-page abstract of a venture capital
pitch yeah the same principle is
applying here which is is it simple
enough that it could be understood by a
wider mass audience the whole point of
this video series is selling a million
bucks the the hidden assumption is to do
that you got to hit the maths
right right a lot of incredible books
have sold 50 000 copies and that's a lot
of books by the way but we're talking a
million here in order to get to a
million you got to hit a big wide fat
mass market audience
and you aren't going to do that if your
book is not shareable
life's little instruction book shareable
seven habits of highly effective people
shareable right don't sweat the small
stuff the monk who sold this ferrari i'm
mentioning these books because if you
flip through them you're like this is
pretty easy to read so then you read it
so then you share it people love sharing
books that they've read they don't like
sharing books that they haven't got
through or that they haven't opened yet
right even though those books get
purchased they don't get shared
so so some elements to add more
breathability pictures
font size using handwritten fonts
handwritten fonts yeah occasionally like
as an actor yeah yeah yeah like and i
think what michael's done with this book
and like i said it's flying
maybe by the time this video comes out
it'll be in a million copies is like you
know he's got seven questions so there's
a listicle format people can latch on to
it tells you which question you're at
then it opens into that question you
know we talked about ryan holliday
earlier in an earlier uh
video in this series
the obstacle is the way he goes the
enemy short chapters really small pieces
of wastelands
exactly yeah so then you're
you get
another great test on the breathability
thing is could you read it on the in the
bathroom
okay and i will tell you honestly one of
the biggest compliments or the most
frequent compliments i get is hey neil
i found this book in my friend's
bathroom wow or
i leave it in my bathroom guests love it
or it sits in our cottage or i leave it
on the corner of my desk when the
students are bored at the end of the
school year like any of those places
communicate breathability
because that means that you can pick it
up and pick it back down or you can jump
into it or jump out of it well i think
with something like that too
there's no order if you jump in on its
date yeah 58
you're still going to learn something
awesome yeah and i didn't put that in
part as part of this thesis because i
think it is possible i know it is
possible to sell millions of books and
have a cohesive narrative structure
right so that's not a deal breaker if
it's not um like this book is you can
jump in and jump out and certainly this
book has it as an order
but that helped for sure because now
it's like the phone book you can just
play around with the thing but the idea
should still be at least how i'm hearing
it i should be able to flip to any
series of pages yeah and see hmm like i
learned something even though i don't
even if it is i have to go in this order
even if i jump in at page 231
yeah i might still learn something
is that because you know what the thing
that we haven't talked about yet here in
this series is that books are daunting
for almost everyone
they are
we are communic we are consuming content
almost every other medium more than
books books are small books are tiny you
can sell five thousand copies and be
number one on the bestseller list right
you sell five thousand tickets to a
movie you aren't even the top ten on the
box office for the weekend right like
we're this books thing is a small
industry right small
small because books are daunting we are
we are taught as children to hate books
because we're forced to read them cover
to cover in the school system and you
didn't even pick which book it was
you got to read king lear and it's in a
language you probably don't understand
and you talk about at infinum and then
you're like i don't think i like reading
uh-uh
you do
you just haven't got a chance to
exercise that muscle yet so yes if your
book can be readable and fun and simple
and accessible and light and pass the
flip test
that people think i could read this i
actually could
that gets you so much cred and helps you
break through the clutter because the
book world
starts from a place of disadvantage
where most people have had it beaten out
of them as children that they don't like
books
one in three americans has not read a
book in the last
in the last year wow yeah and that's
one and three i mean
maybe when you're doing the survey
you're like yeah i read a book i mean
like i'm like that's kind of low i i
would think it'd be even higher i sit
beside people on the planes all the time
i'm like have you read up what are you
reading they're like
nothing nothing is the answer nothing
i'm trying to get people in the game
start with this one it's a kid's book
right it's got 30 words
gotta make it breathable breathable love
it we're talking about finding an empty
ocean
what do you got man well this one's
about being
different being
disruptive finding an empty ocean or an
empty place in the bookstore
that no book like yours
exists yet okay okay so there's a
process to do this uh you have to be
thoughtful about it and so i think first
thing you gotta do is
you gotta look for a really really
really big bookstore
if you're in new york
go to the strand if you're in portland
go to powell's if you're in austin go to
uh
it's a book city down there
forget the name of the bookstore book
people
got it finally if you're in miami go to
books and books if you're in toronto go
to the go to the big indigo or the
world's biggest bookstore bmv right
where we're in toronto anyway find the
biggest bookstore near you
go there and invest in two hours of
wandering that store looking
for the three most similar books to the
one you have either in your mind or that
you've been writing online or whatever
find them
pick them up and hold them
and study them for three things number
one
read the acknowledgements of that book
it's very important that you find the
name of the literary agent
because that's the person that literally
sold the book to editors to buy it okay
so
um i stole this advice from david
sedaris who sold many millions of books
he's a comedy writer humorist and i
asked him way back in the day when i
lined up for him uh to get his autograph
like 10 years ago how do you find a
literary agent he said find the book
similar to yours and read the
acknowledgements
then you find people who literally
are doing that cool you can google them
their names and addresses and emails are
public
you approach them and say i got one
somewhere that's that's for some second
thing you find out from them is where's
the ocean where's the gap where's the
piece of the book market
that does not have what you're writing
or are you adding
to the
like
is there too many books on this topic
already
because you don't want that if you're
like oh i'm gonna i know what i'm gonna
do i'm gonna write a children's book
about hitting
and then you go and there's like 50
children's books about hitting you're
like well now i'm going to be the 51st
right what you want is to go to the
biggest bookstore and discover that
there's no children's books about
hitting
and so you can write that one so you're
looking for an ocean or a gap or some
space
right
around your idea
right
and then what you do this is the
interesting thing is that you you write
down the dewy decimal number okay from
those three books
and you go to the library
i know this sounds funny but bookstores
are organized by category
libraries are organized by the dewey
decimal system
right so melvin dewey was like this guy
150 years ago he made up like a periodic
table type thing for books right you
know three hundreds of psychology five
500's of sciences 700's management you
know this is fiction whatever
because the library is organized by
dewey decimal system you can look up the
dewey decimal number from the three
books that you have already picked out
and find all the books in those
categories again you're looking for an
empty ocean or an empty place to play
what you want is to find very few or
zero books similar to the one that
you're writing or have written or have
in your head okay
why is this important
because you need in this crazy
overwhelmingly cluttered world of
content that we all live in today
with endless books on any topic endless
youtube channels on any topic endless
podcast on any topic
you need
to be different
and different is the hardest thing to be
okay
so
what i'm talking about here is then
therefore deciding oh
you have to answer this sentence evan
you have to be able to say there is no
book about x
so i am writing a book about x okay
right
there is no book about um
how to raise autistic children as a
single stay-at-home dad
so i'm writing a book about how to raise
autistic children as a single
stay-at-home dad okay if your book is
hitting the mark on a topic that people
want but nobody's reading nobody has yet
boom you found an empty ocean so how did
you do with this one i mean this is
coming out huh
what's the process for so on this so so
yeah so let's let's let's go backwards
here um
this book came first
okay the book of awesome 2010. um there
is no book like it there is no book the
only book that i could find that was
like it is a book called fourteen
thousand and one things to be happy
about by barbara ann kipfer the other
reason it's good to find those books
that are similar is because they can
blurb your book so inside this book is a
quote from barbara ann kit for saying
this gives me 14 000 one things to be
happy about the book of awesome so it's
like great to grab a blurb that's
similar but there was literally no other
book that was just a list of positive
simple pleasures with an essay about
them her book is different because
there's no write up it's just 14 000
things
called pillows wetsuit you know whatever
it is mine is like
a commentary on it okay and i noticed
her book by the way i had a million
copies sold on the front so i was like
oh there's no book similar to this but
the one that's closest is also done well
right so i was like cool there's
something there
for you are awesome
first identified a problem that i had
which is uh resilience and anxiety i
noticed that as i have children i have
children um and they have have are
starting to get a little anxiety i'm
like who else's kids have anxiety and
they talk to every parent and they're
like all of our kids do they're all
nervous and stressed and the world these
days is so overwhelming and complicated
that kids these days are anxious and
we're feeling anxious about our kids
anxiety
the interesting thing that i noticed was
nobody
is dealing with
largely war
famine
uh starvation like major depres like
major like economic depression like
we're living in the most abundant time
ever in human civilization yet we have
the highest ever anxiety rates so i
wrote this book as a way to address
things like anxiety mental illness for
inside myself and hopefully for other
people and i could not find a book that
was doing that in an accessible simple
way giving people a model for resilience
that wasn't based on deep academic
research although that's backing up
everything i'm saying but rather on
simple little tools guidelines and
frameworks that anybody could do
in order to get through your day a
little bit easier
so
one of the things for example is i talk
about this way to like clear your
anxieties in the morning by doing this
two minute practice right right which i
referred to already that's just an
example of one of the things from the
book so
i can't help but think
in in our previous video you were
talking about how there's a million
books that are put out every year half a
million from the big publishers half a
million from
publishing every year that's probably
even conservative considering that
self-publishing is so easy so easy and
so huge right so there's a million books
a year already coming out
and so it's
the default thinking is easy to say well
how am i going to be unique when there's
a million every year yeah and then the
first example of talking about well uh
you know single dad who has a statistic
child yeah feels like such a niche thing
but then how do i sell a million bucks
with a tiny little niche topic yeah so
so how do i how do i bridge that gap of
being unique when there's so many books
that are being sold but also being wide
enough that i can have
some significant sales for my book well
it's so so it's interesting you say that
because um
i have so many examples i brought with
me to kind of use as examples but um if
you can pinpoint a niche on the head you
can nail it the market can actually be
gigantic
sounds small right sounds small uh
autistic single
father okay but there's probably
millions of people in that same boat
around the world or that are growing
into that industry or going into that
lifestyle that need that and they don't
know they need that and in the process
of writing it yeah and by the way i'm
we're talking about selling a million
books but i'm not
you can't just aim for the it can't just
be like
everyone loves it right like it's too
big and vague i think that if you go to
a bookstore and you walk around and you
have a unique idea in your brain or you
have a vision for what you want it
actually is pretty likely that you won't
find a similar book
i think it's actually pretty likely
because
um the bookstore
is curating for you
what's popular or what's selling that's
why i didn't say go to amazon right
because they have everything
i'm like saying go to a big bookstore
then go to an airport bookstore then go
to independent bookstore and
independent's a great way to go because
then you see like what is popular enough
that it stood the test of time and it's
being sold in the book that only books
only has like 500 books in it
right so then you find gaps that are in
the mass space that you can write to but
your point is valid like i'm like i
don't know the perfect answer i just
think that if you can nail
an industry on the head
you then can still go big
this is the world's first ever
uh
children's book
that is interactive and hyper-realistic
okay meaning that the graphics in here
like you tap the earth the earth gets
bigger you tap it again it gets bigger
you zoom into the earth kids love it
right and then you flip so so there's
never been a children's book that's
interactive and realistic i partnered
with the animation studio that works
with the discovery channel to make this
thing okay okay so
it sold really well yeah and
it
wasn't that unique
but there was nothing specifically just
like this when it came out so there was
lots of interactive books right lots of
realistic books
i just did something that no one else
had done before
so do you walk to the kids section then
yeah of the bookstore yeah and you look
at
so inspirations for this were like um uh
the very hungry caterpillar it's an
interactive book you got the holes in it
and stuff like that okay press here you
know that book you i don't know if you
read this serious i don't know you press
the yellow dot and like the dots split
up tap the magic tree i'm like oh i love
those interactive works where you
pretend to play with it okay but i want
one that's like you're zooming into
outer space you blow on the waves okay
the waves get bigger okay you know then
you flip it over your head you're under
water okay you're right like so i wanted
something that was a little bit more
like a guided meditation
and so
when i did press for this book
and people said on
tv shows
what is this book i said it's an
introduction to guided meditation for
children it's interesting yeah because
there was no book that i could think of
that was that way yeah
how would it work for fiction same thing
well fiction i think may be even easier
because your idea and your voice and
your authentic self is by definition
going to be pretty
unique i think so i i don't write
fiction so i'm always stretching when we
talk about fiction although i should be
able to answer that because that's what
the video is about but i just think that
when you write your story
of course it's your story you might
start by copying and start by imitating
voices but right as it keeps going
it's even more you so if i have a sci-fi
book in my head of his future alien
civilization but the problem get it out
but but but if i did then the process
would be go to the bookstore look at
sci-fi see what's selling well bookstore
on amazon look for the gap look for the
empty ocean i heard garyvee also say
that in an era where there's endless
supply of content meaning that
everybody's putting content out in every
channel in every way it's overwhelming
the only chance you have
to stick out is by being your truest and
most authentic self
so before you go to the bookstore before
you look for empty ocean decide inside
yourself what you want to be writing
don't say oh there's i'm not saying go
to the bookstore find a gap and write to
that that's not what i'm saying i'm
saying
do the inner work first
start your blog first
start your youtube channel first
hone your voice first
find your fans first then look for the
positioning and where it can go that no
one's doing there's no guided
introduction to guided meditation for
kids that i could find there's no list
of simple pleasures there's no simple
book on happiness that you could just
understand to like figure out how it
happens
to me
and you're a reader too so don't forget
when you go to the bookstore the answer
isn't is there one for somebody else
it's is there a book that i would buy on
this topic
and if there isn't perfect
you're gonna write it
what about using amazon and seeing how
the books are selling well or how to
pick which category that you want your
book it's fine to do that the only
problem is and i've heard lots of this
advice people say go on the rankings and
then check where the gaps are look at
the three-star reviews because threesome
reviews tell you like what's missing
from the books okay the only problem is
then i then i worry about like are you
really writing authentically like are
you writing to sell a book that sells
that's not what i'm trying to do i'm
trying to write a book that's yours and
that's really good
that's why i'm talking voice that's why
i'm talking fans then we can talk about
the marketing and the sales stuff
but it's got to be your thing i'm not
selling them writing a book to sell it
i'm not talking about writing a book as
a business card here i'm talking about
writing an awesome book that you were
proud of on your death bed because
you're like i contributed to something
to the global conversation
and that you can be proud of so i don't
study all these metrics and rankings and
look at it that way i just think of your
idea first and then see where it fits
and if it doesn't fit
or if you're not if it's overwhelmingly
full
you will have therefore a more difficult
climb to find fans find a literary agent
find a publisher because every step of
the way people are going to say like
that's already been done
how much is it if i if somebody's trying
to get a lit agent trying to get a
publisher you come with your idea guided
meditation for kids yeah
how much of it then needs to be kind of
positioned and managed and tweaked to
get
the deal to get the sale it's amazing so
it's amazing because um
uh
this book
about a month before it was published
the book of awesome what's called the
other side of the pillow okay i even
have the cover i can give it to you if
you want to post it here and a 199 other
awesome things in life okay we had a
cover it was it had a pillow on it was
orange okay and a few months before
publication the editor said
that looks like a book about insomnia
okay she's like it looks like a book
that you would read if you're having
trouble sleeping
so it completely changed the title the
framing the positioning
i'd already written the book right no
words changed
but we haven't got to title yet we're
going to get there that's going to be
it's going to know
not to not skipping ahead guys not not
to give you like a like a like um
spoiler yeah we're gonna get to title
but like there's an example where the
entire title
positioning cover completely changed
right just before and then austin became
i mean the brand yeah exactly yeah
exactly so that's the other thing is
that like we haven't got to that yet
either but there's something about
ownability yet that's something that you
can own okay so so what that's like
number seven in the video series man
we're not even there yet jumping ahead
what i'm hearing is
you need to you need to figure out your
own
voice and your own first what you're
trying to create yes but then it's got
to match it to some kind of positioning
yeah you're not just trying to chase the
market you're not just trying to
position it in a certain way for people
because i think that's disingenuous
right and i think the market sniffs that
out pretty quick right you're like oh
you're the seventh book you're right
you're you're like you know a minestrone
soup for the golfer soul you're like
someone's did that right you know don't
do that find your voice first
then
see where it fits right maybe it's that
maybe what we're getting to through the
conversation is yeah it's got to be
somewhere in the middle
of course there's a commercial element
or like it's got 95 you and then that
last five percent is just how do i we'll
change we changed the whole thing right
before but it's the same concept same
book inside exactly but then don't just
go make the book of
of amazing because the book of awesome
did well and by the way anytime you see
a hardcover book come out as a paperback
with a totally different cover happens
all the time what you're hearing the
publisher say is we messed up huh what
you're hearing the publisher say is we
got it wrong let's try something totally
different for the paperback
if the hardcover was sold well they
wouldn't change the cover right but so
often when you see a paperback you're
like what oh this is the same book but a
totally different cover what they're
confessing to is that they got the ocean
wrong they guessed wrong on where it
goes
so now they're trying to position it
totally differently and that's the dance
you play between you and the publisher
and the lit aging different and the
publishers trying to guess the market
and
and if there's proof of concept that's
that's healthier because how do you
balance that like this is what i want to
create yeah especially for first-time
authors yeah this is what i want to
create versus hear the experts who know
what they want to do like i want my
little thing on the inside flap and i
want pictures and they don't want so how
do you know where that you need to fight
for versus
okay these guys are experts so
i
always
got worried about this question
because according to my book deals it's
like the publisher gets last rite of
refusal right so one answer to your
question is in the contracting phase of
a book deal you can say no i get to
decide the final title or i get to but
very few publishers will do that they
typically will not sign that
but they also
aren't going to like stampede over your
face right they want you to sell it with
you crying and screaming right yeah so i
got great advice from seth godin
famous marketing author he's written 19
books like purple cow linchpin tribes
and he said neil whose name is on the
cover
at the end of the day it's your name so
you have to fight for everything you're
not gonna be proud of i'll be honest
with you i pushed back on the cover of
this book even after the title was
changed probably 10 times until we got
this one i'm so glad we did because it's
a winner i pushed back on this title and
cover about nine times
i don't like the cover
i don't like the smiley face okay i said
i don't want a smiley face on my cover
smiley face come on they're like neal
we've shown you nine covers now we're
overruling you and i still look at that
and i'm like if i just pushed one more
time okay
even though it hurts and your skin is so
damaged and you're like i feel like i'm
a jerk
you know you want to pick up the phone
and you're like i just really don't like
that cover
but i only pushed back nine times and i
wouldn't i could guess but i feel like
there was a better cover out there
having said that the book sold 200 000
copies that one particularly so it's
okay
but
you have to love it it's your name on
the cover the channel the answer to your
question is does it pass the death does
it pass the death bed test okay
when i'm on my death bed and you're
thinking back on my book
will i have been proud of the book i
made that's all that really matters at
the end of the day yeah will you have
been proud of your piece of art or your
contribution to the world when you're at
the end of your life and fight for it
fight for it love it one last example on
this exact thing um i signed a
children's book deal i won't say the
name of the publisher just to just to
keep it confidential
and silly me it just said neil pastor
book of awesome children's book signed
the contract got my money all happy
a couple months later i'm like okay i
got my idea it's going to be an
interactive hyper-realistic guided
meditation
and they're like what are you talking
about
it's going to be
crossword puzzles stickers oh wow 6.99
you know we're printed around the world
it'll be dirt cheap we don't even need
you really we're just going to use the
logo and make it kind of simple i'm like
no i want i want something totally
different
called my literary agent she's like well
you can break the book deal
but you'll probably break your
relationship with the publisher too
and i had a choice to make at that point
i had some success
so i broke the deal
and then i put the concept together for
this on a piece of paper like a word
document what i wanted we shopped it
again found a new publisher who liked it
and the book came out right that's
that's the story of it won at the end
right but i could have easily broke the
deal and never found anyone again and
then i just don't have a book so you
have to decide it comes down to your own
principles and your own integrity what
do you want
if you're so clear about your vision it
makes it easier for other people to
agree with you or for you to say i'm out
if you're like i don't really know then
they're then you don't get to decide
right you get decided for
and props to
penguin penguin publishing campaign came
through for
signing up for the guiding meditation
exactly they took a risk yeah they took
a risk cool how to find the perfect
title for your book
so what do you got man
okay finding the perfect title that's a
hard question
because here's the thing we've talked
about it a couple times already but
people are
too busy
they don't have time
they don't have attention
if you think about a book in funnel
marketing terms the number of people who
enter the funnel of looking at your
cover
is much higher than the number people
who buy and read your book so you're
trying to convert i'm using words that i
don't really know myself but like you're
trying to convert
book lookers right into book readers
right and the only way to do that
is to have your title
and your cover
be captivating and interesting and
provocative and capturable enough that
you're like what is this
right how many books when you walk into
a bookstore
if you walk into a big bookstore you're
probably walking by
just argue for arguments like 10 or 20
000 books okay you might pick up five
you might buy one
so i'm just showing you there's the
there's the little funnel there like 10
000 covers
five you pick up that you maybe do the
flip test or you read a few pages or you
read the back you check a blurb and then
maybe one that you buy and it's in the
bookstore it's already the 10 000 most
popular that's that's the other thing
right amazon's got 100 million books on
it so we're talking about the books
that's already trying to curate it if
you're at a if you're at the airport
bookstore you might look at all the book
covers but they only have 50 buck covers
right so you pick the one that you might
take on your plane if you even bought
one at all you might just get youtubes
and keep going
so there's three principles
that you need to follow okay think of
your cover
and i notice that most books break these
and they don't sell okay so i do believe
in these i didn't learn what these were
and i've made mistakes i'm going to show
you okay i wanted i made a huge error on
this one which i'm about to tell you
about okay and knock over all my
dominoes um so here's the thing let's
start with this one yeah uh the first
principle
is ownable ownable ownable ownable you
know this this is you
believe yeah you have
one word yeah you live by it you swear
by it you own it when i think believe i
think evan carmichael
um
and certainly second most importantly i
don't think of anyone else okay great
okay right i mean i'll top my head i'm
like believe that's you right that's in
my head yeah you own that word cool
awesome
is ownable what does ownable mean it
means no one else is using it right or
uh if they are using it they you are
going to use it bigger than them okay so
like jen sincero wrote a book called you
are a badass okay that book has sold
millions of copies she owns the word
badass mark manson wrote a book called
the subtle art of not giving a [ __ ] it
was one of the first books ever to use
the f word right in the title
i'd say arguably he owns that one
he owns the effort because who else has
the f word right and no wonder his
sequel is called everything is f'ed
right because he owns the effort and if
the first thing is it has to be ownable
um one word it has a sentence
it could be a word it could be a color
scheme it could be a branding here's the
thing malcolm gladwell i would say he
owns the white book cover with the small
icon in the center okay the tipping
point has the match
you know outliers has the little beads
right uh blink i can't remember what the
pictures of but he owns the what if you
think white book jacket with a small
like prescient like little impactful
little icon that's malcolm gladwell
of course many people will try to copy
it but because he was the first because
he is the biggest
he owns it right i would argue that
mitch album owns the small tiny packaged
little book tuesdays with maury five
people you meet in heaven
uh
you know these books with like kind of
like a little gold or embossed navy blue
or you can kind of picture it and all
those books look that way chicken soup
for the soul sold millions of coffees
you can picture them white chicken soup
that's a phrase they can own no other
book has that that red cursive font
ownable and if you're a new author or
first time author this is even more
important because you got to stick out
the cluttered marketplace
find a word no one else is using find a
phrase no one else is using find a color
no one else is using find a size no one
else is using right i can grab some some
examples like like here's one
coaching habit okay uh ownable who else
is when you think coaching this guy's on
his way to selling a million bucks this
is what you're going to think to you
can't think of many books off the top of
your head that have that words you can
therefore own it it can be a space that
you can play in awesome is ownable hence
awesome is everywhere i have a couple
sequels that you don't have here
and you are awesome as the new book
because i found the word i own and by
the way interestingly enough i've been
talking for a few years about
intentional living
i thought my writing was all about
gratitude then i thought it was about
happiness and gratitude now i think it's
about intentional living so the subtitle
of this new book is nine secrets to
getting stronger and living an
intentional life this is my attempt
to try
to own a new phrase
and if it works and if we like it and
people resonate with it and they're
starting to see a reaction to it that's
what i'm thinking i'm writing underneath
now on the next book or the next part i
can i can call that book maybe um
not like yeah yeah but it's fine and
it's fine but like i can use that phrase
a little bit bigger right okay yeah
okay can i tell you about a mistake i
made yeah yeah okay well there's no
awesome here okay so you could argue
that that's a mistake right off the bat
you know that's my f we were trying to
change the positioning have him be more
authoritative you know the picture of me
here is like i'm wearing a suit in this
one like okay it's a little different
this picture doesn't have a picture
the second principle though is where i
made the mistake is
giftable
giftable
there's no exact science on this but a
very high percentage of books are
purchased
as gifts
mother's day
father's day
graduation if you think about the last
five books you've purchased i'm gonna
guess two or three if not more of them
were actually gifts for other people
right and if you think if i think about
myself nine of the last ten books i
bought were gifts for other people
because i'm always buying my wife a book
or i'm buying my mom something for a
birthday or my niece is turning seven
i'm like five or three kids books so
giftability
is critical
in this industry
and especially nonfiction which is the
area i know the best
every book says something
about your relationship with the person
so when you give somebody a book called
the book of awesome you're saying
you're awesome that's why so many people
bought this book for their teacher okay
you are a badass i mentioned it earlier
you were literally declaring that person
to be a badass right
well that's a nice thing that you want
from somebody
here's the mistake i made this is called
the happiness equation as i started to
sign books for it we haven't talked
about science now it's just mistake but
it's also sold a couple hundred thousand
right so yeah so a mistake in air quotes
okay yes but here's the mistake is that
that people in line up would say oh i
want i think oh should i make it out to
you or your husband or wife and they'd
be like oh make it out to my husband oh
wait a minute
i can't make it up to him he's gonna
think
that i think he's not happy
if i give you a book called the
happiness equation i'm declaring you to
be unhappy right if you're happy you
wouldn't need the book to fill you up
so does it pass this test of could i
give it to someone and what does that
say
that's a huge thing
it's a huge thing you know um because a
lot of books if you have a book like
with so this book could have easily had
the word anxiety in the title or
resilience right that's also really what
this book is about
right it's a it could have been called
nine ways to live a resilient life
that's that's
nine things in it they all teach you how
to be a bit stronger
but then i thought
if i give you that book i'm kind of
declaring you to be a bit weak
or like would you buy that book for your
anxious or
resilience needing teen
you might not because then it looks like
a book that they should be reading or
like you're like hey you need help right
right so you want the gift ability to be
strong
okay so how would you look at my my
first book your one word yeah
how would you it's called your one word
it's called your own word how would you
why did i think it was called belief
does that say believe on the cover as
well
no i don't think it actually your one
word is belief right yes so it's helping
other people find their one word yeah so
it's not i would think that that is not
it's not ownable
that's the first thing yeah and by the
way ownable is a mistake for most books
yeah i call this the happiness equation
gretchen rubin owns that word happiness
the happiness project right
right so i'm entering into a market
where someone else owns the word right
and that's not a good thing so if you
have a book come out that has like
badass in the title yeah you lose right
right off the bat so you're one were
what i hear personally and i don't mean
to say this in any way negative to you
it's like none of those three words are
ownable okay got to believe vulnerable
so believe and then how would you
for the giftability part yeah your one
word doesn't say anything
right so you need a subtitle or the
graphic or the image has to communicate
that i believe in you
how do we communicate that through here
but this is fun we're a little like
workshopping
but we can say like it's like um
uh
you know something about that subtitle
or that title or the graphic has to
communicate that you believe in the
person right i believe in you by giving
you maybe that's what it's called i
believe in you maybe okay and i'm
spitballing okay without knowing your
book's content in particular in depth
but i'm saying somehow the title
has so for example
uh justin halpern uh wrote a great book
sold a million copies called [ __ ] my dad
says yep
it's totally ownable yeah it's based on
his twitter feed has the s word in the
title which is ownable no one had done
that at that time it was 10 years ago
but then the second book was called i
suck at girls okay didn't sell too well
i don't think justin would mind me
saying that uh i know him
but he
didn't use the ownability from the first
one
and now what are you saying when i give
that to you
you suck at girls right like it doesn't
give you something that you can get
better at right the one minute manager
seven habits of highly affected people
if i give you seven habits of highly
effective people i'm saying you're an
effective person or you could be one
right
one minute manager i'm saying you're a
good manager or you could be one i can
see it in you it's a gift book i and so
many books are gifts
so
you know just think about think about
the gift ability of it it's very
important third piece of principle
on title is searchability okay
i hate to get into the brass tacks of
the stuff
at the end of the day people have to be
able to find your book
so meaning when they start typing into
amazon or
uh
indigo or barnes and noble or they start
typing into google or they look for it
in a bookstore
they have to be able to search for it
and find it
this is why nobody can find the band
named the band
right right
or the da
da that's the hard one to find now and
why the band always do you know the
toronto band always no so they spell
their name a l
okay a-y-s okay it looks like a w right
but when it's alv
it's they own all search right it's
weird to sort of back into search engine
optimization on your title i'm not
saying it should be the core issue right
ownable first right giftable second
these are priority order but then
searchable okay and that's another
problem with the happiness equation
because when you go into happiness
there's too many
it's a it's a
there's there's this gigantic section
and they all have the word happiness in
the title got it and now people will
call me to my face and say like oh i
loved your book the happiness project
i'm like no my book's the happiest
equation
and they're like oh what i thought it
was called just like i just did with you
but it wasn't because of anything
malicious it was just that in their
brain it got confused because i'm
entering a category that i don't own
yeah and i'm playing a game that i can't
win it's not giftable it's not ownable
it can't take off right yeah that's my
personal view you're right it's still a
couple of thousand copies so something
but i think it could have
been another million so
okay so
play with the title on this one
what should it have been to follow these
rules
you know what's interesting i wrote this
book as a 300 page love letter to my
unborn child on how to live a happy life
okay i actually part of me wanted to
call this book dear son love dad okay
and i thought that would be great
because
i think it's ownable it sounds like a
letter to your child i think it's
giftable because if you're a son or a
dad yeah it's so
yeah your son loved it and it basically
says what you want someone to say
and i think then it might have taken off
uh
but who's to say that was just my other
choice was dear son love dad would you
would you it really and it literally was
and again back to our other video the
last one it has to be offensive to the
content right i couldn't of course i
couldn't have called it like you know
yeah climb everest and you open it
what's this book about right but but why
not dear son you're awesome
sure okay that might have been even
better okay right
i wish i had you three years ago when
the book came out
right when you go soft cover
but when i'm standing at a book table
and people say which one do you want to
give to your spouse they always pick
yeah oh i want him to be awesome for her
to be awesome yeah right and and here's
like oh they might think i'll buy this
one for myself right now most of my
advice in this whole video series is
about what i know which is physical
books right if you're an audiobook
person and you're an audiobook junkie
and you've succeeded in the audiobook
universe you might totally disagree with
me because you could say
that's a self-fulfilling marketplace
you're buying an audiobook typically for
you it's hard to gift an audiobook
so maybe there
a book like three ways to get rid of
your anxiety maybe that would work right
so
how do your sales break down
percentage-wise i'm like almost all
physical books all physical like like 90
did you do the your own audio i did mine
you read it you read it yeah i read that
my own self i read that myself but my
books and so part of what i'm speaking
to in my own experience of course that's
the nature of all these videos and all
all your channels that you get my thing
you asked me because i sold a million
books yeah so i can only give you my
view but my books have sold like 90
physical books
um and then maybe 10 or audio in the
ebook okay yeah
yeah and how about
good or bad but right or wrong there's
no there's no no i love it that's killed
a lot of trees but
how about um
when you're going now to different
languages when you're selling yeah
you've sold a bunch of foreign rights
for your books do you try to keep the
word awesome in there do you oh
do you find a japanese version of it
that kind of can i show you some covers
okay okay okay ready read feel smile
okay so so explain this to me i can't
explain it i have no idea okay but but
but
here's the ones that you're talking
about amazon.com you got some
best-seller there obviously
but you
if i look at this is what this
is yeah so this is this yeah so it's
it's two kids looking out a window with
their dogs that's right feels totally
different than
than so but does this bother you how
about this one this isn't this is uh i
think this is mandarin okay but that's
closer there you go they got the logo
that one's thai i think right so close
right super close and that's what most
of them did one of them copied the black
on the rainbow right so but you can see
like this one's um arabic
happiest equation yeah it's so close
right they kept that happy face but then
many of them go totally wildly different
like that's
right right looks like amazon logo a
little there that one doesn't that looks
like a textbook yeah what language is
that don't know i can't guess because i
i'd get it wrong and be embarrassed
happiness look yeah totally off
but but is it is it the right call is it
the wrong call is it what no idea okay
the thing about foreign rights is you
really just don't know i mean
communication is pretty small between
like i don't i get a note in my email
box saying like you sold a foreign right
and i say woohoo and i buy myself a nice
dinner
and i get some copies mailed to me right
months later but
it's hard to really know once in a while
a publisher will get on the phone and
say
hey do you want to come down to brazil
and i'd be like sure and then
i won't or it just doesn't happen or i
do a couple radio interviews right but
it's not this doesn't turn into anything
big right so
so just to summarize yeah first thing is
it has to be ownable grab a word a
phrase a color a size a shape something
unique to you
okay
right
then it's got to be giftable a high
percentage of books are sold as
gifts
is it something that i would be proud to
buy for somebody else i would be proud
to give to somebody else it says
something about me or our relationship
as as i exchange it and third thing is
searchable findable can people in the
enter your category locate you yep
you know that could also that speaks to
the search terminology of it right so
when you type it into amazon or whatever
you can find it it comes up that's big
you know that might be a mistake for
this one because there's a lot of books
that probably have a very similar title
and format so we have to differentiate
somehow maybe that's with our logo but
the world's too big right not to take
these three principles seriously so so
let's workshop it a bit i'll be selfish
and hopefully people can learn from it
too so
if i'm writing a book
on
obviously believe is my thing i own it
yeah it's what people know me for i'm
the believe guy if i'm writing a book on
on purpose
the process i go through is what i call
who why how if you go who your most
important one word your core value
why your purpose comes from your pain
why you do what you do and then how is
how you're going to go up and execute it
if i'm if i'm if i'm doing a book around
that
how should i incorporate those elements
together well the thing you shouldn't do
yeah and this is what happens a lot is
somebody with an extremely popular
podcast
or an extremely popular youtube channel
or an extremely popular instagram feed
does a book and they change the name
this is very common i just told you we
were going to call this thing the other
side of the pillow right my blog's
called a thousand awesome things right
we went all the way to the finish line
with the other side of the pillow as the
title we've made a cover yeah
and i won't use friends and mind as
examples but most of them do this
a guy who didn't do that is humans of
new york right the channel is called
humans of new york the book's called
humans of new york it's our instinct as
people to fudge stuff too much we want
to change it we want to mess it around
we want to make it better or different
no if you have a popular podcast use
that title use that logo use that
branding if you haven't pop popular
youtube channel you already have a
popular title logo and branding if
people know you as evan carmichael or as
the belief guy great but if they're like
if i say oh yeah you know evan's channel
they're like what's one's that i'm like
you know the guy that does like
10 rules like you know 10 leadership
lessons from steve jobs and then people
like oh yeah and they can picture the
logo and they
now they know it because people don't at
least in my opinion i'm a step removed
from your world so i could be wrong
i don't know any youtube channels
i just know videos that i've watched and
i've liked and then i click on something
right like i don't have a personal
connection with too many
uh other than some friends
and so i would need this in order for my
brain to catch it in a bookstore i need
the exact same color the exact same
title the exact same image that i see on
the front page of that channel has to be
right on that front of that book okay
otherwise
i cannot make that leap okay and maybe
we did you know here we go i'm making
leaps here that's a harder one to do
that's why this word awesome is on six
of my book covers and i i probably won't
use happiness again because i it's a i
can't own it right it's harder to gift
it's harder to find intentional
i i learned the lesson that's why i'm
teaching you this thing because it's
like i learned it the hard way how to
plant the right launch seeds yes this is
it this is what everybody wants to know
how did we launch neil what do you got
well it's worth pointing out evan i
think that we're on number six yeah out
of 10 and we're only now getting to the
launch yeah so the previous five things
on sharpening your voice on finding your
fans on getting the title we just talked
about like this is all way before the
book even comes out so we're more than
halfway through the 10 part video series
yeah and only now are we starting to
talk about the launch and that's partly
the principle here is that so much of
this is about
pre-work homework groundwork legwork
work that's all in service is something
that's going to come later okay
now let's talk about launch
we're going to do two things on launch
and one of them's going to be this one
and the next one is coming
the number one indicator
for how successful a book is going to be
is how successful its launch
is okay
it is extremely difficult
to have a poor book launch and to sell a
million copies okay
it is much easier to have a huge book
launch
and then it let it roll and roll and
roll because once a book gets there
grabs onto a couple best seller lists
gets front of placement in some
bookstores gets on a couple big youtube
channels people are talking about it
then the ripple effect can happen
naturally the word of mouth can happen
naturally that i heard someone told me
about this can happen naturally but in
order to get that you need the launch in
order to get the launch you gotta plant
some launch seeds
think about a last time you or the
viewers
bought a book
before it came out
before it came out
you probably for most people would say
never yeah
even though
the number one indicator publishers and
retailers use as a way to determine what
a book's trajectory might be is actually
the number of pre-orders a book gets
so this is a really weird paradox you
and me and the average person has never
bought a book before it comes out
average person i've actually been
starting to do it more and more now
but yet it's the biggest indicator
because of course the people that are
pre-ordering your book are like super
fans right and mom and dad right
so the first thing you have to think
about is why should someone pre-order
your buck why should they give you money
when they can't even do the flip-ability
test in the bookstore they can't even
hold the thing
so it harkens back to number two in this
series where we talk about finding your
fans they have to know and trust your
brain and your brand and your value and
your writing already so they think well
this person's written all this stuff i
like so i'll probably like this that's
one
the second thing is you need to
incentivize them you need to offer them
a bonus
or an extra or some benefits
to getting
the book early you can be very open
about this you can say in publishing in
the publishing world pre-orders are very
important because they determine how
many books a a retailer might buy if
they buy more they feature at the front
of the store it's all coming back to
this pre-order thing and you my reader
because i found you know we're talking
already it's before the book comes out
i've met my reader
um is for you i know you probably don't
want to do it so if you pre-order it
here's what you get i have a friend
named humble the poet he just launched a
book called unlearn he said anyone that
appears in a book i send you a
personalized shout out okay that's it it
didn't cost him any money takes some
time he does little selfie videos like
you know um
diane and in puerto rico thanks so much
for ringing and just that he sends it to
them
so simple yeah but it's a piece of
additional value for someone that
already has a platform and does not have
a one-on-one connection
a lot of business authors
typically typically offer like bonuses
so like a guy like james clear who wrote
atomic habits or ryan holiday who we've
talked about before they might say you
might get an extra chapter that's not in
the book you might get a couple bonuses
you might get a worksheet on how you can
use this at your company you might get
and typically this stuff is delivered
via pdf auto email you can do a lot of
work to make the content really high
value but then it's as simple as a form
on your website or a way to like
register and then it just kicks out the
goodies right okay and what are those
goodies for you it's up to you for the
book of awesome i i ordered ten thousand
i was a bit ambitious okay i ordered ten
thousand magnets
postcards and stickers
saying things like everyone needs some
awesome or whatever i think i printed
some stickers that said like i love snow
days and i love all dangerous playground
equipment some mention of the book and
literally my mom and my sister
like stuffed envelopes and hand wrote
and mailed them out
and i know it doesn't sound like much
but maybe a thousand people pre-ordered
the book from that
and i ordered ten thousand so my parents
still have like nine thousand of these
things in their closet
but
a thousand was enough of a sign to the
publishers and the research that hey a
thousand people bought this thing in
advance
before it even came out so that's one
way to plant your laundry is work really
hard on what you're offering someone in
order to do the pre-order campaign and
like i said it could just be as a selfie
video it's something like little fun it
doesn't have to i wouldn't do the
mailing thing because it's a huge
logistic nightmare right right and you
have to pay for all the postage
number two
what's the other way that you decide
whether or not to buy a book when it
first comes out
very simple for everybody it's the same
thing reviews
if i tell you that a book came out two
weeks ago and i send you the link on an
online retailer's website and it has one
review
and it's five stars you're like the
guy's mom
or the woman's husband right or the kids
the person's dad like you're like that's
not a real review yeah
so it's actually quantity
of review that matters more than the
rating at the beginning
because most books will have
two reviews five maybe ten
so how do you get a lot of reviews
it's a challenging puzzle amazon knows
it's a challenging puzzle so they offer
a service called the vine program where
you can convince your publisher to buy
reviews
um
what that means is that people that are
part of this program choose your book
they can choose from many products they
give it a legitimate authentic review i
know this for sure because people are
viewing but they're like one star even
though i got this for free it still
stinks right so it's not like you're
getting like baked reviews five-star
you're you're genuinely gonna get
yeah whatever people's authentic reviews
but it gets the number of you reviews up
the even though they're more they're
more likely to be strangers who don't
know your brain who are most likely
going to review it lower than somebody
who's a super fan i think that it's a
possible risk too the other thing i do
um and i've done this on all my books
although i'm surprised most people more
people don't do it is before your book
comes out something else is printed
beforehand it's called um
a review copy uh sometimes it's called
an arc arc advanced review copy or a
galley okay so um
at the time of recording this video this
book has a galley but it's not come out
this doesn't come out till november
right so
normally a publisher says okay neil you
get 10 copies of a galley and i always
say yeah can i have a thousand right and
they usually say yes and if worst case
scenario they say oh yeah but it'll be
like a doll or a book or something from
the time the galleys are printed to the
time the book comes out i literally just
keep like five in my backpack at all
times yeah
no
major vested interest other than when i
bump into somebody on a plane when i
meet somebody on a bus when i'm at my
in-laws house with 10 people at a
christmas party whatever i like give
people the book in advance why do i do
that so that when the book comes out i
can say hey everyone i gave the book in
advance to if you if you read it
and
some don't yeah then could you leave me
a review and that helps the review get
helps the book get like a hundred
reviews or 50 reviews even out of the
gate and even 50 is enough of a sign so
that when someone visits the website
they see that the book is kind of being
read and they get an honest opinion i
never ask anyone for a five star review
ever i never say like please make a
five-star i don't do that i say can you
give me an honest review
you just want an honest review and
people are just looking for someone
besides the author telling them what the
thing is right right are those are those
two good numbers for somebody who's just
trying to yeah get started a thousand
pre-order copies and 50
reviews yeah i love the way your brain
works you want the actual numbers you
know um i know it's i know it's like
just football parks i know some big
authors yeah i know some very big
authors they'll get 10 or 20 000
pre-orders okay and now we're talking
because that might even be enough to
crack the new york times bestsellers on
the first day right right that's amazing
i'm sure michelle obama got a hundred
thousand pre-orders right
what do you need to hit the new york
times bestsellers there's no there's no
absolute number right a rough ten to
twenty thousand yeah
that would be a good general rule of
thumb but i say there's no absolute
number because i know people have sold
more and i'm not making it and if people
sold less i made it it also depends on
christmas time right it might be 50 000
in in february when no one's buying
books it might be 3 000 and your book
comes out that month
and it's curated which means the new
york times can decide what's in what's
out right it's not like a spit out of
bookscan or booknet right they're
literally the nielsen pos sales data
it's not that some newspapers use that i
believe the wall street journal does i
know in canada the global mail does but
your times is editorialized
so
it's you don't really know how to make
it and they protect the fact that you
don't know how to make it right right so
we can get into a whole deep
conversation about how to make new times
past our list the only way i've made new
york times bestsellers is when i have
national media
so if i'm on the today show
it makes then my books ratchet up there
because people all saw me on some big tv
show but even that these days is much
more splintered less people watch tv
more people watch evan carmichael
right
and all the other people on youtube and
all the other people on instagram and
television all that stuff okay so i said
two things already number one um i was
just talking about reviews okay and
before that i was saying
pre-orders okay what's the third way
uh you can try to plant launch seeds
okay here's the third way
find a thousand tribes
who naturally exist who naturally want
your book
so
for a book about gratitude
what i spent some time doing is saying
who online
is already in this
purview who already loves this stuff
teachers
are a good example they want exercises
for their classroom
what teacher websites i went to go speak
at teacher conferences for free i just
like let me tell them about it you know
this book is about resilience so we're
thinking like okay what are some
tribes some groups that are naturally
oriented towards resilience
and what are their podcasts and even
though the podcast might have 500
listeners total
they might be 500 people who are
naturally oriented towards your book's
theme
so
yes it's nice when you make the today
show right and courses will help your
book if you're going to be on
good morning america
or the front page of the wall street
journal but that's mass
and there's something about small
targeted repeated
and you can do a lot of that stuff
before the launch so what's the process
reveal down if you said teachers okay so
what am i doing i'm looking at linkedin
and looking for teachers okay so
okay let's talk about teachers for
example
um what i would do is i would go to the
apple podcast app
and i would type in any search term you
could think of
if you were a teacher if so my wife is a
teacher so i would say leslie what
podcast would you listen to oh well my
friends are listening to this one or she
goes on there and types in like
education like you can type in
all these search terms looking for them
the next thing is look at the number of
reviews that we're doing the same thing
on each other how many reviews does the
podcast have zero
50 a thousand it tells you something
about how popular it is how list how
people listen to it
there's nothing wrong with the zero
review show it's just like
check
then listen to it
do you think you might connect with the
host do you think you might connect with
um
do they even have guests on the show
right otherwise you're pitching a show
and they're like we don't even have
guests dumbass like didn't you listen to
it right so
you got to do your homework search for
the shows this is just
i'm just talking about podcasts just
searching for them then checking reviews
then listening to them then once you
have got that far you personally
not your assistant not your team you hi
my name is neil pasricha i listen to
this episode here's why i liked it i
have a new book on this book on this
theme here's why i think you might like
it can i send you a copy of the book
that's it and then all you do is follow
up 30 days later saying did you get the
copy do you think it would be a nice fit
for for a conversation
and if they don't reply to you ever
again worst case scenario is you lost an
email of time and you lost a book of
time right and you listen to a podcast
of time exactly are you are you then you
physically mailing out the book and yeah
signing it and like bookmarking page 42
because that's geared towards teachers
or you're just ordering from amazon and
you send it off to uh yeah yeah i mail
them out myself i can't order from
amazon the book's not out yet
right this is all this is all before
this is all all the three things i'm
talking about now we'll get to the
launch in the next video yeah but the
next thing i'm talking about is
this is stuff before the launch now your
publisher if you are going through a
traditional publisher should be able to
help you out with that you can start
feeding them names and addresses and
saying hey these are like
30 big podcasters that i think i could
be on yeah these are 30 websites these
are 30 communities it has to be
authentic here's the thing right that's
you can't just like start pitching
people randomly you genuinely have to
find them and they exist the world's so
big
how many youtube channels are there
oriented around results i don't know i
haven't started looking yet but when i
start looking and i find them and i
watch videos and there's a connection
then maybe we can do something together
so so you're in that phase now for this
book yes right you don't have the
physical galleries yet but you've got
e-copies you got this you made this just
for this yeah exactly right no i said i
was coming on evan carmichael they're
like evan carmichael print the biggest
sign you can get
used to fit through the door i'm
grateful
um
so so
your book comes out in november we're
filming this in in
end of june yes you're already starting
to plant in the seeds
how much of your time are you dedicating
now
you can decide how like the things i
just mentioned it's time it's time yeah
it's time i'm talking pre-order campaign
i'm talking thousand reviews or a
thousand galleys that you try to get
reviews on i'm talking looking for a
thousand tribes
the average person who's listening to
this should already feel exhausted right
but we're talking about selling a
million books we're not talking about
selling a thousand right if it was
selling a thousand i wouldn't bother
with this this episode would be moot but
you wanted me to come talk about a
million so i'm telling you you gotta
grind you gotta hustle and all these
three things i'm talking about make a
huge difference and they come from very
authentic places trying to give your own
readers extra value trying to give
people books for free so they can read
it you want people to read the thing
right and then see if they want to i'm
never doing anything pushy if you wanted
to go all in you could hire three
research assistants
you've taught me that you know you can
hire research assistants and you can say
hey try to find podcasts here's my
themes here's my principles then feed me
the ones that i should listen to then
you listen to them then you come up with
like a targeted pitch letter okay you
edit the pitch letter
the top line the bottom line you have a
three or five sentence email you don't
want it to be too long or no one will
read it
you have people ready you have an
assistant ready to be mailing stuff i
mean you can this cavern is deep how
deep do you want to go
you know but the reason it's all before
the launch is because you can record a
lot of these podcasts and episodes
before the launch
even happens so when it comes out what
you're what you're hoping for
when the launch happens you're hoping
for the surround
sound effect right you want people to be
like i heard of that book somewhere and
i don't know where everybody's the
biggest compliment you can get so so
let's break down yours quickly just for
timeline so yeah we're we're four or
five months away from this sure hitting
books i haven't even done most of what
i'm telling you to do yet okay great so
how long did this book take for you to
write oh okay oh you want the whole
history of it okay yeah i wrote the book
in 2017. okay
uh in 2018 i signed with simon schuster
uh we went through a long number of
edits back and forth so it took you a
year to write it yeah well and then a
year to edit it it took me probably i
wrote it in a sprint
um and i wrote it probably three months
but i didn't do anything else for three
months right like i didn't do anything
else i just wrote it period
right then um song with a then sign with
the publisher so we went
we put it into a book proposal right we
pitched it for a publisher
usually what happens is people pick the
most money that they get right right
like this publisher offers me 10 grand
this publisher offers me 50. it's
probably a thousand or 100 then you go
with the biggest that's usually people
do unless they have a vested
relationship or they really want a
particular editor or they have somebody
has a vision for it that you want to do
it's like how you sell a house yeah
you're like you usually go with the
highest bidder unless you're like well
we really like that family right you
know we want them to live in our house
that you might go somewhere else okay
then you find an editor what you're
doing when you find a publisher by the
way is finding an editor someone whose
voice can align with yours someone who
can see where you could go amy einhorn
said to me my editor for the book of
awesome it's a it's it's not a blog to
book it's not a printed of your blog
it's a hardcover it's for soccer moms
it's a gift book she positioned it that
way and i was captivated by her vision
so that's partly what you're choosing
when you choose a publisher you're
choosing the editor that's going to edit
in this case i was lucky to have two
editors lauren spiegel in the us and
nita pronovost in canada
both amazing editors and been really
lucky to work with them
so nita did the lead role in editing
with two energy one person has taken the
lead nida was the lead
she added multiple versions then is that
and that's a full year of editing like
yeah basically it's like as if i did the
math i'm like yeah it's probably a year
of just editing okay like the way
editing works is here you go here's a
300 page word document yeah and then a
month later they're like
here you go back right you're like
okay a month later you're like here you
go back track changes so it takes yeah
track changes yeah here we go and it's
like a month at a time this gigantic hot
potato right like
the world's slowest game of pong you
know
so
it's like really like that so i'd say it
takes a year but like it's just like i'm
hustling and then i take a break and
then just
then of course another kind of six to
nine months of
putting it in the catalogs for the book
publishers equipping the sales force uh
with the information they can tell the
retailers about it you have to sell to
the retailers how many copies is walmart
gonna buy zero hundred thousand fifty
thousand they decide based on their
space in store
how many books they're going to feature
should this be one of the ones that they
feature why or why not what's their
focus in their store and every this is
all happening through the back end
then it gets time for months out yeah
now we're in the process of like covers
finalized right we're in the process of
uh i'm looking for blurbs now whose name
is going to be at the top saying this
book is good like we're asking people to
do that right so
there's all that kind of stuff and then
there's like first pass second pass
third pass which means the final book is
given to you and you find out that
there's 10 commas missing
okay or you're like oh i don't want that
person my acknowledgements anymore we
had to break up whatever it is you
change right and then and then you keep
going and then you keep going then this
is all the pre-launch stuff and now i'm
talking pre-launch campaign reviews
campaign and finding a thousand tribes
that are related to your book's central
theme and once you have your launch date
you you personally neil prescription
goes hardcore on the seeds
four months before i mean he wants to
four six i mean i also want to take like
summer vacation with my family so i mean
i might not be as hardcore as i was when
i was young single and alone right
working 22 hours a day i mean like
it you get out what you put in right
but
i will i also have a reputation now
where i can call up some old friends and
be like i was on your podcast for the
last one or i was on your right and
they're like yeah great to have you back
so there's less work the more you do it
right i'm talking to the first time
author or the first time person who i
think is watching this
saying
that's why i'm laying out all the
groundwork yeah deeply right so so for
that like pre-order campaign by the way
the first time i had no email list right
now i've got a big email list so it's a
little easier to get pre-orders right so
they've if they've gone to the first
time author yeah they've written the
book they've gotten it edited
i have a i have something ready to sell
in there huh how long should i wait
until i actually sell it oh i'm doing on
premium six months probably six months
six months three to six months at least
yeah just because of all the stuff i'm
telling you about it takes a long time
yeah it takes a really long time that's
a full-time job that's it that's a three
day a week i mean yes what you put in
what you put out i always try to nail
you on these yeah but but for somebody
who's trying to budget their time is it
like this is full-time if you were to
put a full-time job into this yeah
taking it very seriously with the
ultimate goal of spreading your work
it i i feel like your book is going to
be a hit
because you're sowing all those seeds to
bloom when the book comes out and how
great would it be when your book comes
out if you have a thousand people you
said a thousand true fans already saying
right when it comes out
i already read it
i really liked it you should get it too
and check out the reviews there's
already a hundred up there somehow yeah
you know and of course you'll get a few
saying those are fake
but they don't realize that all you've
been doing for months is like giving
people the book so they can read it and
check it out right and then if you
listen to the podcast they like on the
topic that you've written about
or the youtube channel that
that they're already watching and you're
on there because you took time to like
connect with somebody and offer them
some real value off you could also do
things for the channel the best thing to
do for the channel or the pockets is to
give them something that they want
back in the day this used to be would
you like five free copies for a contest
right right would you would you like me
to to do something for your channel that
would help you like what would the
person want that would be helpful for
them and give them that
you go on you you go on youtube channels
or or podcasts that have nothing to do
with your perfect theme because the
theme like my podcast is called three
books i'm looking for the three most
formative books of inspiring people
right i've interviewed
malcolm gladwell chris anderson judy
bloom
partly they come on my show because they
have a book out but when they come on my
show i ask them about the three books
that they've read right actually it's
not related so you end up doing stuff
like that that's not perfectly related
but still it's giving them what they
want right right so i'm only trying to
serve you want to give people what they
want for their channel for their podcast
and then if in the intro i'm sure
they're like and he's got a new book out
that's enough
you can't be harping on the thing
forever
cool i love it and take it seriously for
months it's a full time
job
or you know or it won't work or won't
work or or you or you get to we got
another video coming on get called get
lucky you could just get lucky this
video these this teach me that this
forget all the others well this is gonna
get lucky which is not for the people to
get lucky this video is for people that
work hard at it because that's who i can
that's what i can talk about this is
episode seven where we're talking about
doing the launch hustle
what do you got man okay well it's
almost like you just
on the last video we just did
right chapter seven episode seven this
is seven last one was six okay on six
planting the launch seeds planting the
launch season you just basically you
squeeze out of me okay you gotta work
like full time for three to six months
i'm like do i really do that do i i mean
i guess i do
but now we're talking about the actual
launch hustle yep now you do okay this
is this is like the book is out today
yeah okay you are going
i think you need to treat a book launch
like a full-time job for as long as you
can afford to okay okay so some people
are like well i have a full-time job
so this might not work
uh other people might say well
i'm working on some other project this
happens a lot of people right they're
like i have i have a full-time youtube
channel i'm running i have a full-time
podcast i'm doing like i can't dedicate
three to six months but if you got
nothing else going on or you're able to
sublimate what's the word like put that
stuff under this lower prioritize that
stuff then i'm saying go three to six
months with your book launch being your
full-time job wow okay
okay
parts of that
might be things that the publisher
organizes for you or with you a book
tour maybe maybe some bookstore events
right maybe do some pr some press but i
need you
if you really want to sell a million
books you have to think of it like a
book launch is like your full-time job
for three to six months
okay so the first thing you got to do
before right before your book comes out
right as you are coming out is thinking
uh okay i just spent two years
writing my book selling my book editing
my book designing my book working on my
book and right at the end
you have to think wait a minute no one
cares about my book no one knows who i
am
i mean nothing in the grand scheme of
the universe
what people
are caring about or thinking about is a
question mark that you have to answer
okay what's in the news what are the
major trends what are the natural issues
of our times what's the national
conversation that's happening okay
so
um
is it about
uh free speech
is it about rising anxiety trends and
adolescence
is it about bullying is it about gun
violence it
find those things
find those things
and figure out
how or if your work
fits into that naturally
so i'm saying you spend two years
writing this thing now you've got your
work of art it's all ready to go
and right before it comes out you got to
think wait a minute i mean nothing
what's everyone else talking about
and only if you can answer that question
can you do what i think is most
important is write your talking points
okay
so when the book of austin came out i
was working at walmart i worked there
for 10 years there was a guy in the pr
department he's like oh your brook's
telling me that next week i said yeah he
said what are your talking points i was
like
what's the talking point what are you
talking about he's like you know you're
four or five points i was like what four
or five points what are you what are you
talking about he's like well what are
you gonna say when you're interviewed
and i'm like i'm gonna answer whatever
they asked me he's like oh no don't
answer whatever they ask you
figure out what you're trying to tell
them
so i worked with this guy his name is
kevin he was working with me at walmart
he's like oh my gosh he's like
right now everyone's talking about uh
anxiety okay he's like does this help
with that he said yeah of course it
helps with that i'm using it to get out
of my own you know i went through a
divorce i went i lost a friend so of
course it's helping with my mental
health he's like perfect so why don't
you say you know uh
that is one of your lines and for those
who are battling with with mental
illness or depression they'll relate to
that so there's one talking point what
else and he kept pushing me on this
thing until i had like four or five
sentences
that literally became evident i'm not
joking the same interview i did
50 times
right
but
your talking points are actually
hung
on your books content and the national
conversation you've got to slip into
something that people are already
thinking and talking about
i'm not saying that this would have fit
into gun violence right like i i you
can't connect what doesn't exist
but i'm saying
there's big conversations happening up
there that you are not part of could you
be part of them how so right right so
what was the big one for you for for
this one book of awesome book of awesome
was at the time the book of awesome came
out in 2010 2010 yeah it was like stock
markets at an all-time low
ice caps are melting
there's like
huge unemployment rates there's pirates
like literally there's pirates in the
seas i don't know if you remember that's
a big story about pirates so the talking
point is in a world that's gone to crap
you know what i mean like
cheer yourself up the way i cheer myself
up you know what one awesome thing a day
in order to put myself in a better mood
here i am a year later um uh am i
perfectly fixed no
but in a world where the news is so
heavy this book gave me a little break
right so anyone that was listening was
like wait a minute that's that's me i'm
i'm so depressed by the news it's
overwhelming i've lost my job
they connect with that okay with this
book
i'm discovering
uh
and i know it's partly
some of it should naturally happen once
you write it uh it's like
there's a lot of anxiety mental illness
is rising depression is rising
loneliness is rising
there's a reason why we put and you
can't see it in the frame here but it
says the sub headline is nine secrets to
getting stronger and living an
intentional life we put that phrase
getting stronger in there because i was
like
that's what's missing for me and for a
lot of people is strength
right now in the world with how much
stress there is we have two choices we
can hide at home and put our heads under
the covers or we can thicken our skin
and be ready to face that future
with a more confident and a more
kind of able-bodied approach
to
the stresses that are going to come our
way
and so i haven't weaved it into a
talking point yet but you see a talking
point is a small simple sentence that
people can get and understand that's why
your book is relevant for the times
because if it's not relevant for the
times
it's not relevant
and is that channel specific so if
you're going to do a national newspaper
obviously you're targeting national
topics if you're going to come on to an
entrepreneurial channel you're going to
talk about it how relates to
entrepreneurship sure is that yeah so i
think write the talking points as a core
first right so that would be like
strength
yeah so this one's intentional living
exactly is it right the the the themes
that come out of the book naturally
right right and some of them might come
from specific chapters right right so i
have a whole chapter in here about um
how to be a big fish in a small pond i
have a whole thing it was a story that
the dean of harvard told me about when i
was there and it was like i think i've
used in my whole life when i when i
started speaking i asked to speak in the
lowest speaking bracket not the highest
because i wanted to like practice on
smaller stages so i i shared that story
and it's like hmm maybe that would work
well on a channel that's to do with um
getting out of a breakup or get
post-divorce or after losing your job
because you're trying to build your
confidence back up so then i can use
that talking point so it's like
yeah you got to write your talking
points to your book but then to your
point you have to tell them who you're
talking with right but if you don't two
weeks before my book came out a week
before the guy is like what are you
talking about i was like i don't know
what you like i thought you just
answered you have to know what you're
going to say first and how it hooks into
why should anyone have you on their tv
show why should anyone have you on the
ratio what's the reason
you have to know the answer to that
i'm assuming with a lot of these talking
points there's multiple stories
underneath that you could potentially
tell so if you're talking about growing
stronger it could be about how to deal
with divorce how to deal with a friend
dying how to deal with uh trying to sell
a new book how to deal with rejection
from whatever how to do with walking
away from a publisher
it could all be related to growing
stronger but the story that you tell
could be contextual to the audience that
you're talking to absolutely okay and i
asked before i did this video
obviously i was super i was like i'm
going to talk about how to sell a
million bucks i was like i never talked
about this before like i'm i'm nervous
through this video i was like this is a
question i've never been asked i i
always just told people like just
happened random like i don't know
but you forced me to think about it so i
gave it a lot of thought and i also
interviewed
um other authors who've done it and i've
asked them what do you think works and
the thing that came back from a few
authors which i think is related to this
point about talking points
is find a controversy
in particular try to find something that
people agree or disagree with in equal
parts
and sometimes the controversy can be
made known to you so this book is called
the happiness equation it has nine
secrets in it one of them
is called never retire
that's a big thing i wrote about
whatever i didn't think much of it
certainly something i believe i had all
the research in there i have lots of
reasons why you should never retire if
you want to be happy don't retire
retiring you're giving up your i have
all this research about giving up your
social connections you're giving up the
structure in your life you're giving up
the learning you're giving up your the
story you're part of something bigger
don't retire it's dumb
right turns out
people who are retired don't like to
hear that right so i'm suddenly doing
national call and radio shows
taking calls like me and the host and
they're like well i don't know what this
guy thinks i'm retired and i love
playing golf every day so you're a bozo
that's like but what you're hearing
there is something that's controversial
yeah so then i wrote an article about
that chapter for however business review
it went viral like it gets a lot of pick
up so then um
i'm i'm talking to you now three years
after this came out
tomorrow i'm on national npr radio
talking about never retire
still
three years later i did the launch
hustle three years ago but still that
point turned out to be controversial and
if it's controversial people want to
talk about it i had another chapter in
that book called how to make more money
than a harvard mba
okay
now that title is perfectly
controversial and you can do that like
the four hour work week by tim ferriss
that's a purposefully controversial
title yeah
nobody works four hours a week everyone
works 40. tim does certainly not work
four hours a week right but the title
has baked in controversy so you're like
what
what does that mean how can you do that
how will i discover
you know how about chris gillabo the
hundred dollar startup yeah
controversial how can you start a
company for a hundred bucks
probably i don't know i haven't asked
chris directly i'm gonna guess that's
his best-selling book because it's the
most controversial title how about the
one minute manager
huge popular million copy best-selling
book
how do you manage somebody in one minute
in fact for our work we kind of like
related to that yeah right even the
things that are like you know like eat
chocolate and be skinny or like i'm
making it up but like if it's so
outlandishly controversial of course
people are gonna wanna talk about it
they wanna know
why you're full of crap right to try to
disprove you
or they want to see what you're selling
and the remote chance you might be
telling them truthful
right so back to what we've talked on in
previous videos
most of it is still like it's supposed
to be authentic recording your message
if you believe in not retiring i do but
then it's looking through your content
and saying okay what in here
could be controversial in this modern
time exactly or or literally what
question like that call-in show thing
that's it came up i learned it
i didn't know it was because the host
read my book right and he kept picking
on that so i was like why is he picking
up and then the calls kept coming they
were angry at me and i'm like i'm the
awesome guy no one yells at me usually
right but they're yelling at me and i'm
like then there's you realize there's
something there so what's controversial
in here
so many things are in this book so like
so one of the most controversial things
i say is is this idea of telling
yourself a different story okay okay so
for my podcast three books i interviewed
seth godin and one of his three most
formative books the whole premise on my
podcast is tell me the three books that
changed your life was a book called the
book of est okay so er hard seminars
training from like the 70s he read the
book
it hit him and he realized i go to a
good school i'm actually not too
badly off yet the story in my mind is
that i'm
aw shucks i'm always like i'm
pessimistic i'm glass half empty most
people are like this in general
and he's like i just realized i could
just tell myself a different story so i
researched this topic for the book and
turns out
this is you might say it's ignorance is
bliss but i'm gonna go out in this book
and say
honestly if you're getting through a
breakup if you're getting through a
divorce if and i go through my own
things in here and i won't go through
them in depth now but i talk about like
body issues i've had all this stuff like
that
um
just tell yourself a different story man
like just almost like lie to yourself
okay like um i have a chapter in here
called have you had enough one night
stands right
kind of a controversial title the
premise of that is though is that when
you go through a breakup there's
research that shows that the average
person has 16 relationships has 16
one-night stands has broken up with
three times is cheated on once like all
this whole litany of terrible stuff that
you would never want
but the research shows that that's the
average steps the average person goes
through to get to a solid loving
marriage if they get to that
so the question to ask yourself when you
go through these breakups is have you
had enough of them
because that's the path to get there
that's the path to get there so tell
yourself a different story meaning that
if something really bad happened just
allow yourself to get out of it right
okay like get your mindset snap out of
it and two is
uh
have you had enough one night stands
you personally having carmichael you
know i'm just kidding
but that but
it's enough of a headline that it could
grab someone's right so would you do a
call-in show with like give me your
worst
problems give me what what yeah you're
buried under a mountain of crap right
now and you feel like you're the you
have the worst life of any human alive
call in
and then you and then you say hey let me
fix your story like exactly the kind of
stuff you could talk about or like
literally like i think right now in the
world and that's partly why i wrote the
book is
we feel like crap yeah in general
as people
like we live in the most abundant time
ever in human civilization and yet we're
the least happy to be here
loneliness rates have doubled since the
1980s 40 percent of us live alone now
more than ever before anxiety is up uh
mental illness is up depression's up
suicide's up
what's going on yeah and when you talk
to people it's like well i compare
myself to others on instagram i've got
social anxiety i never turn my phone off
i'm sleep there's all this litany of
technological stuff
and
psychological stuff that's happening to
us so part of the premise of you are
awesome is to go through all of that and
remind us that you know what you are
awesome and here's some of the ways to
rethink the failures and stresses and
pitfalls you're having in your life so
that you can get through them and get
over them and be okay part of the reason
i wrote this book is because something's
going to happen to me at some point not
going to be here forever my chancellor
and my kids are still going to be alive
and i know that their life is relatively
soft there's no starvation there's no
famine there's no great depression
there's no economic collapse
we got clean water in our taps
so when they hit
real hard falls real hardships a real
breakup a real divorce
um loss of a friend an accident an
illness
loss of job
they're not going to be equipped with
the tool set
to get through it
so the book is an offering to people
like my children on like how to navigate
those challenges when they come because
we're all an army of porcelain dolls
right now you get a nasty email from
your boss people cry about it for three
days like we're soft me too so this is a
book to toughen ourselves up okay what i
loved in that sentence was also you said
part of the reason why i wrote this book
yeah right like there's a reason why you
gotta have that and you wrote that in
2010 so exactly no exactly so if you
share that why if you share your
authentic reason for writing it yeah
people love that
i was going through a divorce and i lost
a good friend i wrote an awesome thing a
day for a thousand straight days
when i got remarried my wife leslie told
me she was pregnant on the plane home
from our honeymoon when we landed in
toronto i wrote a 300 page love letter
to my unborn child on how to live a
happy life that's this book
after we had children my parents my
children inspire me to see the world
through their eyes they love being
rained on they love playing in the sand
this is a reminder to adults and
children of all ages on how to see
awesome everywhere
now that my kids are growing up a little
bit i see that they have some stress and
anxiety i can't understand it because
the world seems so easy to me it seems
like
we have everything
but i talk to parents
other parents and they say we also have
anxiety about our kids anxiety
in a world where everyone's a bit soft
how do we strengthen ourselves how do we
toughen ourselves up and how do we
navigate those inevitable failures and
bumps in the road this book is that book
for my kids so it's like those are the
authentic stories yeah of the books but
then people will be gripped but more by
it because you're vulnerable enough to
share it then everyone goes on tv
talking about the divorce it's not like
i was comfortable i was not comfortable
doing that at the beginning
i just said oh i wrote this to
i like i like warm underwear from the
dryer like i didn't my talking points
originally had nothing to do with that i
was not comfortable at first but the
more authentic you can share your story
the more people will be attracted to it
well we started off this clip talking
about how you have to make your
message fit the times yes
i guess what's going through my head is
the reason why you wrote the book also
fits the times
because you're living in the times
exactly
so no matter who's watching this video
right now chances are the thing you're
writing is relevant right because
otherwise you want to read it so just
explain it that story wrote it i'm a
writer i said rit don't edit that out
it's funny
so but explaining the story the reason
the authentic vulnerable piece of why
you're creating even with fiction like
why do you create these fictional
characters yeah what's the story behind
it there's always themes underneath the
stars right and explain
art makes people feel and writing is art
exactly and so what's what's what's the
feeling that you had in creating this
what's the intention behind and then be
able to share it so i interviewed angie
thomas for my podcast she wrote a book
called the hate u give
it's a fiction young adult novel sold
many millions of copies it's about
a black unarmed teen getting shot by a
white police officer okay as a young
adult book
when you talk to her she's angry about
racism in our society right and that is
palpable when you read her beautiful
fictional tale
of what happens in a society in a
village in a school when somebody is
shot an armed black teen is shot by a
police officer of course the book sold
millions of copies because it touched on
the deep emotional nerve center that she
felt so passionately about that we could
feel while reading it and whatever
you're feeling going through chances are
there's a ton of people feeling the same
thing here's the first rule to tell you
a million books feel something yeah and
make that feeling go into your work if
you've got nothing inside you then you
can't have anything on the paper sign
sign sign sign sign sign baby what do
you mean well on an earlier a part of
the series for those that have watched
kind of all the ones leading up to this
point
i i shared how most of my books have
sold in physical copies as opposed to
audio or digital okay um so this advice
is a little bit biased towards physical
here's the thing
a signed book is special
it's special how many signed books do
you have on your bookshelf if any
zero one i got some i got one from you
you going for me yeah this one you gave
me this one and have you thrown it out
no it's there on my bookshelf because
you probably won't throw it out because
it's not it's
reaches significantly touch this book
there's dna on it exactly a dna dna oh
but the point is that you can say to
your your partner or your husband or
your wife you can say like check it out
i got i got a signed book or i got a
signed book for you right when you move
it moves with you i'm at an age now
where i'm starting to get people saying
like i have it in college and i got it
in high school and i've carried it with
me like there's something special about
a signed book it is unique
it is rare it is human we live in a c
algorithms now people if you can get
something that's a real human connection
it's valuable so the first thing to do
and by the way it's not just valuable
for the for the person who has the book
it's value for you as the author because
signed books have a rate of sale that
are five to ten times higher than a
standard book okay the proof is you walk
into a bookstore and the one at the
front that says autographed copy first
of all it's partly placed there because
it was autographed right so it gets
better placement largely it's not
returnable so the store is gonna keep it
there because it's like a special book
signed in the store they're not gonna
send it back and thirdly someone's more
likely to buy it because they're like oh
this is special i couldn't just buy this
online i couldn't just go home and buy
this tomorrow i just bought a signed tom
wolf book for like 35 at an airport in
milwaukee because it was signed right i
didn't want to carry this giant tome
home but i was like tom wolf's dead this
book is signed i gotta get this copy and
i paid a lot of money for it signed
books are special
now how do you do it first thing is you
gotta equip the bat belt the bat belt
this is the bat belt i recommend a
skinny thin black pencil case it's i
keep this in my in my backpack at all
times i have had this thing on me for 10
years if i lose i'll have to buy a new
one what's in the bath belt
okay first thing you need
this is important signed by author
stickers
signed book is worthless if no one knows
it's signed right and half the stores
have their own stickers the other half
uh don't so you got to order your own
online or when the stores have lots and
you're like can i take some extras for
your other
stores that don't have any they usually
give you some so keep signed books
second thing is so you're going into the
stores and saying hey i'm neil patrick
yeah i've written these books
i'd be happy to sign them for you before
we even get to that clip the bat belt
i'm going to tell you the different ways
to sign okay because because we're going
to get to that that's going to be step
two and three okay they told me i had 15
minutes i'm going on a rant okay okay
second thing you need is you need a
signature okay and it's not just the
night before this book came out the book
of awesome i went to the bookstore near
my house downtown toronto biggest
bookstore and i said you have any signed
books oh that one signed that one signed
it was just someone scribbled like it
was just like someone just wrote their
scribble name i was like that's not
special so i went out i bought colored
sharpies i got all kinds of different
rainbows it reflects the color of the
book okay right yep right i got colored
then i went and um i got this it's
probably my backpack i got a stamp made
at staples okay cause you are awesome i
got a stamp made now i got colored
sharpies and i got a stamp yeah where
did i get that idea from frank warren
okay good friend of mine he writes the
books post secret website postsecret.com
he has a stamp that says free your
secrets and become who you are okay and
he signs it in like a silver font okay
okay chris hatfield the famous astronaut
he draws a picture of like a rocket ship
with his name
something special okay you gotta have
like think of like uh the joker he
leaves like a little joker card whenever
he comes what's your like what's your
like
you know your key signature what's your
special move what's your you got joker
you got batman belt yes yeah i got a
little batman theme but think of like uh
you think of like a finishing move in
mortal kombat
you gotta have something that's uniquely
you okay so that was mine was the
colored sharpies next
you also need book plates okay what are
book plates your pup
since like the 1800s if you look inside
a lot of books they make stickers that
say like this book belongs to
you put your name on it
publishers still make these and if they
don't you can get your own made but
publishers make them for me for free i
just say can i have a box of book plates
so this one says the happiness equation
has the my website on it my name
oftentimes you're signing a book that
doesn't exist physically in between the
person the person's like hey i have your
book at home
my sister has that book
oh do you want to book plate for it or
often on the internet someone emails me
i just bought three copies of your book
for my team and i say oh do you want us
to mail you book plates you say yeah in
fact i'll buy 10 more for the whole team
right i had a guy that's vice president
of sales at like a huge company he's
like i got 2 000 people in my sales
force i was like do you want to sign
book for the mall sure he buys two
thousand books i mail them 2000 of these
so you got to have that in your back
belt i like it and then you got to have
some sort of i keep some printed
material that i can just give to people
if they don't have a book and don't want
a book can't afford a book have a
library book
in this case i have my podcast as a
bookmark and as a sticker okay so i
print these myself
at the end of the day it costs very very
little yeah but it's calling out
something i'm working on something i can
sign i can give to somebody people are
embarrassed unfortunately when they say
like
basically don't have the money to buy a
30 book and i don't blame them yeah but
then i still want to give them something
and you have something nice to give them
cool okay
now that the back belt's equipped this
is going to get to your other question
okay how do you sign books
number one rule for life for any author
and no a lot of people don't do this but
i'm talking about selling a million
books here is never drive past a
bookstore again
ever
if you see a bookstore that's a stop
sign
you stop you get out you walk in you say
hi
my name's neil i i wrote a book i don't
know if you carry it
it's called this
book of awesome they look it up yeah we
have four copies in the back
blow the dust off and here you go sir
you signed them guess where they put
them they put the stickers on them they
put them at the front or the cash i told
you the rate of sale goes up most
importantly someone gets something
special so i sign all stock it's called
stock when the books just sit in the
shelves
in all stores that i ever go past in my
whole life okay i also have a rule which
is whenever i'm in a bookstore i buy a
book
like i just have a like i just want to
buy a book i'm a fan of books of your
own no oh something else like like what
i'm saying is
if you're going through all these
independent bookstores and you're
walking into bookstores
support the store too
like
when you go and sign books and you leave
it there you're saying thanks for
selling my book one thing that's nice to
do is
hopefully you like reading because
you're an author
buy a book support them talk to them
about what they're reading book sellers
know more about books than anyone
because they talk to people about books
all day they see what people are asking
for that they don't have
publishers don't do that authors don't
do that
they're like everyone's asking for a
book about x we don't have it
what's selling what's not like they tell
you everything and you can just have a
conversation buy a book to support them
sign your books
great it's a great relationship and you
know what
they will tell the story of meeting you
and talking to you for years because you
maybe were interesting you had a funny
story or you were a nice guy right
doesn't cost anything to be nice
so that's for a second i think sign
books at all stores and you can even
take a little further and go to
warehouses okay i have been to
warehouses so you ask big retailers hey
christmas is coming you want me to sign
the thousand books you have in the
warehouse i have literally gone
to the indigo warehouse okay and signed
a skit of my books i took packs of
sharpies had people assisting me we
stickered them all so now all books in
the whole chain nice as they get
distributed say sign by author write on
them and that'd be for new orders that
are coming out yeah but but the
warehouse always has tons of books in it
so it's like now
and white horse or the middle of montana
there might be a signed book that i
never could get to that bookstore but
it's signed so sign all stock in all
bookstores why not just do why not just
always do
the ones in inventory yeah because it's
not as easy to do that first of all
where's the warehouse relative to where
you are i told you the chain that's
based in toronto second of all how much
inventory does the chain have like are
you making a personal bookseller
connection there no because the
bookstores are in bookstores sure
there's all these reasons okay
the other thing that goes along with
this is um sometimes you'll be signing
books with lineups they're either author
signing events in my case i do a lot of
speaking events it's the end of my
speech say i speak from 9 to 10 am i
speaking for 500 people and they all got
a copy of the happiness equation
well of those 500 people
300 of them will wait in line to talk to
me 200 are like thanks but i i want to
go to the pool right
what the natural human tendency is to do
is to say
do this
but a few years ago i got my book signed
by david sedaris and it changed my life
okay david sedaris stole many millions
of books he's a humorist
he's from raleigh in north carolina he's
uh he writes books about
autobiographical funny essays i saw him
speak at massey hall in toronto the show
ended at like i want to say 10 p.m
i went to the basement to get him to
sign my book i was still there at 1 am
my cell phone had died because i had run
out of battery i hated david sedaris i
was mad at him i couldn't believe he
made me wait three hours but when i got
to the front line he just looked up at
me
he's like
hey
i'm like
hey i'm
and there's a pause i'm like i'm a big
fan of your work i've been reading it
for years he's like thank you he waited
again
when he waited over and over again i had
the opportunity to do everything i
wanted to i could lead the conversation
i could tell him the story i could ask
him a personal question
and it took like five minutes and i
could tell like
no one's going to end this except me so
i was like well i better get going
and i left
do you know how many signed books i have
on my bookshelf probably 50. i'm a big
book fan and i love signed books
uh do you know how many book signs i
really remember
one that one with david sedaris what
you're really trying to do when you sign
a book is to create a memory so when i'm
in line or when i'm at the front of the
line after at a book signing event
or after a speech
it's your time i will text your son in
college i will call your daughter in the
hospital i will take pictures with you
and your friends i will write a personal
story if somebody wants the book signed
to their boyfriend or girlfriend i say
what's your name they say sarah i say
joe sarah and i think you're awesome
like conclude them in the story of it
use the colors what's your trademark
include a bookmark now they don't just
have a signed book but they also have a
memory
and that is life it's just life is just
a bunch of memories in a row but you
made a memory for them
and i don't remember all the people i've
signed books for but i know it's a big
percentage of the million
because of it adds up from all the stock
all the signings and the more signings
you do
the more you get to do
and how do you manage that lineup like a
nightclub you're a baller in the corner
of a miami nightclub getting bottle
service what do i mean i mean you need
someone on pictures like literally
someone helping you take because every
phone's different you know you need
someone
uh tagging the book so working the
lineup and with the yellow uh sticky
putting like the name on the front so it
can help you like so like you know
sometimes names are hard to spell you
want to kind of help there
um go slow if the line's really short
like really slow like don't let them
leave yeah and then it's long you can go
a little faster it's still their time i
still let them control it the way david
sedaris did for me
but you know a publicist will run up and
say excuse me like if it goes too long
you know like there is eventually a hard
stop if someone's like wait until the
end have like a million questions or
whatever
but
i can't emphasize this enough this is
something that not many people do
and it makes a huge difference
you remember you have one signed book on
your bookshelf it's from me how perfect
and we didn't plan that you aren't going
to throw it out because it's signed so
it's a bit special it's not in the in
the book cabinet over there right like
it's special and now you've got a memory
and a totem and a souvenir and a story
all wrapped up around this book and that
is perfect for word of mouth it's
perfect for telling people about it it's
perfect for actually reading it it's
perfect for actually doing what the
whole book is supposed to do which is
get out there
sign sign sign it helps everything in
the whole
cell in a million book story it's this
thing what's going through my head for
for people who
they don't have an audience yeah as big
or they're worried that nobody's going
to show up to the book signing that was
part two we already said find your fans
first so you have your fans already i
mean otherwise you're back there that
you can't publish this book until you
got your fans and and if you're a
first-time debut novelist yeah
out of the gate
there are people like that i just i just
my personal experience i can't speak to
that i only know the way to sell a
million books through non-fiction
through having them like that's my story
so i'm sharing that but i think finding
your fans is important at the beginning
but you're saying okay if you don't have
them then what well but i'm just trying
to think now how do
how do you start getting more of these
signed opportunities so what you're
saying is every time every time you're
doing a speaking gig you're also selling
books and you're doing a signing at the
end right i'll tell you how to do it
okay you go into all the bookstores near
your house
and you say simply this
may i do a book signing here
and they will say yes because bookstores
like having authors and they're doing
bookstores they might say no if it's
like the week before christmas and you
want to be there saturday morning or
something right but just being kind to
them and respectful to them they'll say
yes
now it's a humbling moment because
you're walking into a bookstore either
with your own book if it's
self-published or off the shelf if it's
not they have to usually order up so if
they keep two books of your store in
stock maybe they're ordering 50 right
for this big moment your saturday
morning in november
and i say it's humbling because you're
sitting at a stand you got your book on
display
no one knows who you are right no one
knows your book
you got three hours
just make the 12 people you talk to
important
be honest be a genuine interesting
person or interested in them
and maybe you sell five ten books
they only carried two of your books
before
so i just told you you sold more than
double their inventory in one spurt
right
you made a connection with book sellers
so when you ask them again they'll say
yes or no right but they have a
connection there they've referred to
your book you've signed your stock there
now the stock is their sign which
increases the rate of sale you have five
or ten people that now have could read
it and could do a review or could tell
other people about it that's not
worthless that's still worth something
and i just gave you arguably the worst
case scenario
right i know people that do this and
they go like to different books every
saturday morning
right
yeah so you can do that too it's
grinding it's hustling it's work it's
time
but
this is called how to sell a million
bucks so of course i'm telling you all
these things as you're talking the thing
that's going through my head too with
that is content that's content like film
it that becomes a youtube video
of course that becomes a vlog that
becomes an instagram so so it doesn't
only have to be wasted time in that
yes you're invested in relationships yes
you sold 14 books or two or whatever you
sign this but that could also be
potentially content
sure plus it's not just content to put
on your own channel it's also you're
living life in an interesting way and
that creates stories and thoughts and
ideas and some will say what's this
about is it about that you're like oh
what a weird thing you get you get
reactions and feedback in real time on
your own work and that's so healthy
you know i i often feel bad so i've seen
a lot of authors in stores yeah um who
nobody's talking to them they're sitting
at their table super humbling yeah
nobody's talking about that so i'll just
i'll just because they're an
entrepreneur i love entrepreneurs so
just tell me what's this book about do
you buy the book sometimes see i and you
know what people might be watching this
thinking like oh well this guy's easy
for him to say he sold a million bucks
dude i've been sitting at the front of
walmart's and literally everyone's like
where's the pet food
they don't even like it's like a
disaster like i have done we need to
vlog that is content that is content i
have had like no one at line i mean i'm
like what am i doing but don't forget
you're also making a relationship with
the retailer your connection with the
book seller you make
there's all kinds of benefits there yeah
so
yes signing books is key
and doing so increases the rate of sale
increases the connectivity and creates
memories for people never never stop
what do you got man okay well we've done
two parts already on the buckle launch
remember sowing the seeds hustling for
the laundry you've got to grind for
three to six months pitching like crazy
getting your talking points straight
that and i said at the beginning of that
part i was like
the number one indicator to a book
success is how well it does at the
launch right right so that was really
important number two how well it keeps
going
right a book can have a great launch and
drop off or a book could be a slow
burner out of the gate and if it keeps
slow burning
it might
keep slow burning and that's good too my
editor of my first book used to say
i'd rather have a consistent seller over
a best seller okay because i would say
oh i really want to make the new york
times best sellers and she's like neil
most of those books are like
they're like pop on pop off
i'd rather have a consistent seller than
a best seller we talked about who moved
my cheese do you ever see that in the
best seller list it's selling way more
copies in almost anyone's book but it's
just below the radar right ryan hall
they would call this a perennial seller
yep okay right so there's a lot of books
like that
so how how do you do that
never never stop
it is a marathon not a sprint
here's some things i do number one i put
my personal email address in all my
books
and in some cases my address like a
candle box right but i have a connective
tissue right away for people to reach me
of course you could do this through
socials or use a hashtag but have a way
for people that want to when they get to
the end of your book reach me okay go
ahead i got an email this morning from a
woman like and university saying that
this book has changed your life you owe
me a huge essay and all this stuff
someone handed to me she wouldn't have
done that if i didn't have my email she
just wouldn't know how to get in touch
with me right so that's a great way to
connect
also when you have your email address
public guess who else contacts you i'm
not kidding
book clubs
in alaska that want you to skype in um
high school newspapers in the middle
east that are doing a profile on you
uh like like a youtube channel like mine
with hardly any subscribers like you'll
get requests up the wazoo
every single one you say no to
is another person who's passionate
enough to love your work enough to
contact you
so don't say no to any of them
do the i do i still do high school
newspaper interviews
i do skype book clubs at least once a
week
so i have my assistant schedule me for
up to two per week okay
and the only rule she puts in is that
it's got to be at least eight people and
they have to read one of my books that's
it but those people tell other people
and they tell other people and they tell
other people and i'm not going to alaska
i'm literally on skype so it doesn't
like it's not like i have to travel and
i'm it's nothing better than sitting in
a room like a living room full of
grandmas and they were like well here's
what after i like here's what i learned
here's why i got this question for you
i've done them with startups in san
francisco i literally say at the bottom
of my email list if you want to skype in
like contact
uh this person here's the email address
and we're good
never never stop never never stop means
never dropping by a bookstore always
stopping and signing never never stop
means wait until the last person in
every lineup i've missed flights before
so that the last person can get their
book signed never never stop means
putting your email address public never
never stop me saying yes to every
request you get
doing everything you possibly can to
keep sharing the story it's a marathon
not a sprint
never stop
and how do you split that up now being
you've got all these books i mean you're
you're now going to be in promotion for
this one but you're still you sold a
million of these two
how do you
well
i mean helping this helps promote these
ones too i was just about to say you
answered the question right in the thing
one way to never never stop is to
serialize okay one way to never never
stop and you can ask jack canfield on
chicken soup for the soul about this
it's
if you got something that's working do
another one
because the sequel sells the original
and the original sells the sequel right
so
there's a reason why
harry potter sold i think 350 million
copies you should really be doing this
interview with jk rowling
sorry that um i'm the the backup here
but jk
joe as i call her
she'd probably tell you i i would i
would i would bet money on this that the
first harry potter is outsold all the
rest
and the reason is because when you come
out with harry potter two people are
like oh how do i enter the series i
start with harry potter one right
similarly the book of awesome goes up
every subsequent book i do
and that's another way to never never
stop is instead of focusing on the
promotional and publicity and sales side
of it when the book comes out which is
important we're not going to gloss over
and say that doesn't matter yeah
spend the time after your hustle three
six months writing the next book
because then when that comes out and has
its own pr and has its own press it has
its own tv shows people go back to the
original and it's no there's no surprise
that when you are awesome comes out i'm
sure the book of awesome will be back on
the front tables again right because
retailers aren't stupid publishers
aren't stupid they're like
they'll probably want both
especially when the connection is so
obvious and you gotta make it obvious
yeah to that point earlier we said about
a title right earlier part of the series
the title has to be ownable yeah so once
you have your like jen sanchez who wrote
you are a badass there's no surprise why
her next book's called you're a badass
and making money you're about like right
something that she and if she doesn't
own a word she can jump
okay
and some people can do it on their name
i don't think i can my last name is
super hard to pronounce neil pastricha
people can't say it they can't spell it
brene brown
there's a good name
bb sounds good it's fun to say brown
everyone knows how to say and spell it
so maybe on her books daring greatly uh
dare to lead uh you know maybe her name
is the
is the ownable part
you know what's interesting because i
was looking at a bunch of naming stories
and one i came across with i think it
was xerox which seems like a like xerox
yeah with an x and with an x yeah um but
it was he purposely picked a name that
was so difficult but once people got it
they never forgot it yeah so once they
get presented there's a copy of the x at
the end yeah once you get pacifica you
don't forget it
you got it at least there's only one
like when you type in your password like
i got my own you know i've been brown
yeah that's tough so many browns yeah
the grasslaw was greener i'd rather have
carmichael you'd rather have parspricha
um yeah i mean so well it could be
ownable anything but the point is i was
trying to make a part of never never
stopping is never never stopping to
write right so what's the time
difference between these two are these
three i guess that's a kid's book i mean
i guess still really in 2010 the first
book yeah what i don't have here
although i have them back here if you
want me to pull them out is the book of
even more awesome 2011 book of holiday
awesome 2011. okay
two books in one year yeah yeah yeah
don't don't forget i've also got like
then what else comes out is like you
want the ownable the journal of awesome
journal pops out with the same logo
i got five calendars of awesome it was
page of day calendars okay 2012 so that
was 13
right then the happiest equation comes
out into this comes out 2015
2016. okay this is 2019
okay there's an audible original in
there in the middle
so it's 10 years now and i'm on seven
books
right
and uh i'm 39 years old at the time of
this filming
if i'm lucky i'll keep going right the
only goal i have in my life as i'm
trying to do it is
make the book good enough that i can do
another one
right i think the average person writes
something like 1.1 books meaning that
nine out of ten people
stop stop at one yeah
only one out of ten will write another
one then again it's probably like less
and less and less right so
i love writing i really enjoy it i find
it really fun and therapeutic to try to
constantly clarify and simplify my own
thoughts to myself this book is
something i read when i'm feeling
stressed that's why i wrote it because i
was feeling stressed so still when i'm
feeling stressed like i'll read it so
i'm writing to myself all all writing
ultimately is quite selfish you're
trying to do something to clarify your
own thoughts or just simplify something
or to make something clear to you so all
i want is permission to do another one
and are you writing every day or are you
breaking from writing to do well i guess
you said in the previous video you spent
yeah you wrote that in the three month
sprint yeah one of these instagram
sprint so so you're in promotion mode
for this this is just ramping up you've
got four months for this to come out yes
then you're going to be in full-time
mode promoting it
yeah for at least three months of just
yeah all day every day i mean and part
of that is like also just doing every
request that comes in every radio
station that comes in every high school
newspaper everyone's just saying yes to
everything and then when do you start
writing the next book so the right the
next book is already being written
while you're doing the promotion okay no
no so i've already started it now i'm in
the process of writing it now it's all
about trust okay that's what my theme is
focused on so the way i'm doing it is i
wrote a new speech about trust i did it
at south by southwest i stress tested
the ideas that way i've been doing a
year of research where it's sitting in
the back of my mind i've had i've hired
a research assistant to like help me dig
up some studies
then i've written like drafts of
chapters so it's sitting in the
background there and then yeah the goal
should be partly of never never stopping
is try to sell the next book before this
book comes out
and the reason you want to do that is
sell to publishers yeah the lit agents
yeah yeah yeah because
you want to know where you're going
for lack of better words uh you want to
know what's next for you and you want to
also have some more buy-in and some more
pro like the way i think of it is
usually you have two books left so
if my next book bombs
and then i have a bomb again
i might be done i might be kicked out of
the pool
two bombs in a row who's gonna want me
after that but if you keep having a hit
then you sell the next one in before the
scene i mean like you you want to try to
get the next one red just like ready so
that you can then have that cooking
while you then work on like you're going
to almost be a book ahead so so before
you're saying
you wrote that book in three months and
you spent a year editing it because it's
back and forth but is it during editing
time that you've been working on the
next one but i i wish i could say
there's one clear answer but don't
forget the book of awesome was literally
a daily blog right so this one was
written every single day for four years
that turned into three books yes i wrote
that uh this one took nine months my
wife told me she was pregnant i wrote it
while she was pregnant until we had the
baby and then
she had the baby i shouldn't say that
she had the baby not me and then
otherwise you get slapped you didn't
have the baby one you didn't even carry
the thing so you
that book then i had written over the
nine months this one i wrote in a three
month sprint partly because i've been so
much busier now that in order to write
now i'm like cut away speeches cut away
promotion cut away media don't do
anything like don't do any meetings
just take three months to write it so
it's more intentional to write today
than it was when i started or i was just
doing like an essay a day right so
that's just my life right now i might
tell you next time we do a video that
i've got a new system but my current
system is carve out time if you're going
to get it done otherwise it won't get
done
so so
in the editing of this is that when
you're then writing the next one on
trust stephen k yes stephen king would
say it takes three months to write a
book
so you write a book for three months
remember though this i said earlier that
you hand it into the publisher right now
what are you doing you're twiddling your
thumbs
until you come back you're writing the
next one then when that one comes back
you haven't looked at it in so long that
it seems fresh to you and you've got all
the edits you've maybe written the next
one or half the next one it comes back
so you you have to have a couple on the
go in order to keep rotating and all the
editing processes though by the way is
this really slow hot potato back and
forth so there's tons of time there to
write if you you're like well i handed
this one in so now i can write that one
so tussle while you wait
hey that's a good phrase yeah that's not
mine i like that i wanted to say mark
twain but i don't know mark twain so
mark twain never said hustle did he
uh i think he should look like abraham
lincoln
i think it was uh
uh from the bible that one
no i'm just kidding no i i
look at i i didn't make it i think you
own it that's ownable i don't know what
book i'll call also while you wait
hustle while you wait but that's
basically what you're saying like you're
waiting so i'm not just gonna twiddle my
thumbs i'm gonna hustle on the next yeah
i should also maybe at this point in the
series mention that i don't watch
television
like
like
the thing that's missing so far from the
conversation is like neil doesn't not
not do free time very well okay
it's like family
work and that's you know like it's like
i don't kind of like chill on the couch
and stare at the ceiling much
well it's intentional because i'm
spending my time doing stuff i purposely
want to do but when people say hey did
you see the news i'm like no did you
read the newspaper no did you check out
the latest magazine issue about this
nope
did you check out this new thing on
netflix i'm like no like so
part of what i want the viewer to be
aware of throughout this entire
conversation that we're having is i'm
making trade-offs like we all are life
is about trade-offs so if you want to
sell a million books there's got to be
trade-offs and one of them is i don't
really know what's on netflix and what's
in the news
lots more but those are just a couple
that come to mind so so the life cycle
of making a book and promoting it is
about three years
hilariously yes
from from thinking about the idea and
writing it and then submitting it
getting it purchased but what's the year
of editing and then there's a year of
like
titling cover distribution sales
promotion yeah it's really like i i
think it's like two to three years but
but then on top of some people take ten
years like you might take seven years to
write it sure right right especially the
first one yeah but if it's if it's three
years it's not three years
and then and then next three years it's
they're stacked yes so like one year and
so you're writing you're working on like
three books at the same time almost
everybody can do it differently the
other thing that we're missing from this
conversation is how many books did you
sell to a publisher so this was a single
book deal yeah this was a double book
deal so i've sold two books to my
publisher now so the next one's already
purchased the trust one yeah the trust
one right so before that one comes out
which maybe that's in 2020 or 2021
before that comes out
my goal would be to
gen like genesis think on
right my next thing right and then sell
that in so i've got the next thing
cooking too
gretchen rubin author of the happiness
project told me that she's like i always
sell in the the book after the one i'm
working on so that i have my next
project kind of starting to go and
that's great for repeat authors right
but your first one you're not going to
sell part deal of course well oh
actually some some first-time authors uh
you have a big blog audience you have a
big email list you have a big platform
you have a proven concept somehow you've
proved the concept they might get a
double book deal out of the gate or a
triple book deal or five five book deal
but they might not even want that okay
you know like you might on the third or
fourth book be like i wish i was on this
thing i wish i was doing something else
so
it all depends some people play the game
for a big advance some people play small
advance
let's try to sell the books and then
get get permission to do another one
you know what's your thought on advance
no advice well i should probably take a
small break to tell people how advances
work okay so advances are again so
against royalties
so say you get a 50 000
advance
uh and say you get a dollar per buck
sold okay which is
average is about a dollar per paperback
three dollars are hardcover if that's a
relatively average industry amount
so say you're doing a paperback book you
get a dollar per book you have to then
sell 50 000 copies of that book to get
up to your advance before every
incremental sale counts for your
royalties
meaning it's not like getting a big
advance
like is necessarily just good in and of
itself it's now a much higher bar you
have to cross in your sales
to then exceed in order to both earn out
it's called you earn out your royalties
yeah but also more importantly like make
the publisher money make you money and
give yourself permission to do another
one right so getting a huge first time
advance
might sound good on paper but i would be
very skeptical and scared of that
personally because i'd be like well what
if this thing doesn't do it then i might
not get another chance and for me i like
the chances i want to keep writing i
want to keep doing this that's why i'm
making this video i like talking about
books there
i live in bookstores i'm in bookstores
almost every day i
like i literally know booksellers in
every bookstore anywhere walk i have
three bookstores open till midnight
walking distance from my house every
night they're up until midnight so i
like literally can go by i know the
people that work to eleven i'm there
every i'm there all the time i love
books so all i want is permission to
keep going
therefore i don't care about the
advances i want permission to keep going
i want to keep doing this and then if
the books keep selling of course you
earn out your advances same money back
to you so then of course you get
permission to keep going because
everyone wants more books from you yeah
this is our last episode number 10 which
is get lucky get lucky how do we get
lucky well evan when you first asked me
to do this yeah i think i said to you
i don't know how to talk about this
because i just got lucky
like
that's always been my response
and i wouldn't have done this video
other than the fact that i thought about
it more and more and i thought i'm just
afraid to do this video
because i actually have been working
hard at this
i think hopefully the previous nine
parts of this series show that some
elements of hard work in there but i do
have some of the original semblance of
that first blush thought which is
partly i just got lucky now
what do i mean get lucky there's three
things i want to say here
first is
hope for a moment
okay
we talked about talking points we talked
about fitting your book into the what
conversation is we talked about that in
earlier parts of the series
but
there's something magical about a moment
where you might have the right book at
the right place at the right time that
you couldn't have
guessed and it just all worked out so
if there's a huge
uh celebrity that dies or something and
you happen to this happens all the time
you look at it you happen to have a book
coming out of that person's
autobiography or that principlography in
like two weeks
boom you got the steve jobs like
literally the steve jobs autobiography
came out like right when he died like he
couldn't have predicted he might have
lived 10 more years
the point is
it randomly happened right you could
also be like a huge news story about a
police shooting police shooting a black
teenager
the hate you give by angie thomas was
like dropping at that time so
boom it's like a moment happens in the
news and there's a book about it at the
same time like this is this is like
random it's it's literally you can't
control that
you can also hope for like uh like like
a golden touch like this happens i have
a friend
uh humble the poet uh he has a book that
just came out called unlearn
okay and he told me like uh
uh you know charlemagne the the guy the
god yeah like he saw the book at some
conference or something like that he
tweeted about it or whatever he reached
out to him has him on his show has him
on the breakfast club
you can't predict that kind of stuff
with this book um in canada there's an
incredible woman named heather reisman
she runs the largest book chain in
canada called indigo
she liked it she made it a heather's
pick
she puts on the front table she says i
really like this book that's like oprah
like that's a golden touch you could
similarly have evan carmichael put you
on his youtube channel or something say
hey guys i don't read many books but
this book i really love that's it my
point is authentic organic random
oprah picks you for her book club reese
witherspoon picture for her book club um
someone who you have no idea how they
got it i mean i have some like just last
week somebody with like hundreds of
thousands of followers on on whatever
instagram reached out to me saying loved
your book friend gave it to me i want to
feature it can you send me a couple
copies sure like that's random yeah
that's luck you can't control that stuff
and
below these two things the random moment
the random touch
what i want people to take away from
this series more than anything else is
if you wrote the book you wanted to if
on your deathbed you can look back and
be like i'm proud of it
if you tried
some of the things i'm talking about
plus some more that i don't talk about
because i don't even know them
but you just care enough about your work
and your art and your book that you want
to give you want to give it to the world
and you want to share it and you did
your best
then at the end of all that evan no
matter what no matter how many books you
sell honestly all you really really
really really need is just to find peace
with that
to find comfort with that knowing that i
did the best book i could i wrote
exactly what i wanted to do it looks
exactly the way i wanted to do it and i
tried really hard to spread it
maybe you sell 5 000 copies maybe you
sell 10 million copies
just knowing that you did it your best
we can all live with that
partly what's driven me over the
previous nine parts of this series is
that i couldn't go to sleep thinking i
didn't try
i wanted to try
so i tried
right but
if you tried and you did your best then
you should be good with that that is all
we're really playing for
and that's why number 10 is get lucky
because certainly in my own story and
i'm sure with anyone that sold over a
million books there's a tremendous
amount of luck i remember hearing an
interview with jack canfield the guy who
did chicken soup for the soul he's like
one day on the cover of usa today one of
the jurors in the o.j simpson trial was
photographed holding chicken soup for
the soul
on the cover of the national newspaper
at the biggest trial of the century
i mean you could argue like was that
lock or was that just
i think that's pretty lucky you can't
randomly make that happen right so like
there's all these random things in the
world that happen
you could also get unlucky you could
have the best book ever
and right before you're about to release
it the president tweets something
terrible and all the airwaves are taken
off the next day and you get bumped from
the today show
that happens i've known that happened to
people that's even happened to me
i got bummed from the today show once
because uh it was the morning after
osama bin laden was assassinated i got
bumped thankfully for my sake i guess
they had me back on the show like months
later but i flew home that day i was
like oh my god like i just missed my
chance because we killed osama bin laden
like something totally out of my control
so much of this stuff is under your
control i've given you nine things that
are in your control that i think you
could do at the end of all that just be
happy that you did it oh and i mean i
love it but how do how do you there's a
lot of people i think who would say man
i'm just so unlucky but then they don't
do all the one to nine yeah and they
just blame it on
bad circumstances well i'm a bit wary
about the fact that the one to nine is
like there's a lot there yeah there's a
lot we went through so much stuff
right
so
try
try your best
do everything i shared with you that i
could think of right this is all my
stuff that i could think of i'm sure i'm
missing lots never never stop and then
be happy with what you got
so i didn't put be lucky at the
beginning i put it at the end you know
on purpose is the acid test just
are you proud of yourself yeah can you
sleep at night did you do your best some
authors by the way have
i've met authors who are so interested
in the sales side of it but not in the
writing i've met authors that are so
interested in the writing side but not
interested in the selling so you do need
both right you do need both you have to
be so passionate about the art and the
craft and the right word and getting
that sentence perfect and editing it ten
times and loving that you have to be
into that and i think these days you
gotta be interested in the hustle you
gotta be interested in staying till the
end of the line to sign everyone's book
stop it at every bookstore you gotta be
interested in saying what type of
traffic is coming to my website from
radio stations
oh why don't i just email all those
radio stations i literally did that for
the book of awesome it's like oh i'm
getting traffic i can see like four hits
from like q107 in calgary i'm like hey
did you guys want me to come on they're
like we love yearbook we were talking
about it so
that's partly hustling but it's also
just i'm just looking at
i'm taking opportunities that are right
there
you know so you gotta have both you
gotta have a writing
passion and a and you gotta have the
passion to to kind of get it shipped
right but are you proud of your effort
every night yes you have to be i mean
maybe because i'm east indian and my
parents were like driven i was supposed
to be a doctor and i failed that's why i
care about i don't know
but like yeah you've got to like be able
to you got to think did i do my best was
there resistance for you from your
parents of like you're going to be an
author what oh my god i didn't even tell
you this yet i had all these books i had
a full-time job
i was working at walmart for 10 years
for five books
and 200 keynote speeches and ted talks
and only then did i have the courage to
say you know what i think i'm going to
do this full time
so even
after
selling a million books
i'm still working my full-time job
because i felt culturally that you got
to have a paycheck who's gonna pay your
dental bills
if you're an author
i pay them now and by the way the
dentist is very expensive
like 400
those used to be on my benefits plan
but you don't have a benefits plan
anymore
so what is their book number or for
authors who are who are watching wanting
to get started wants us to be their
career they're working walmart they may
be are okay with the job but i don't
know people love their job working at
walmart
at what point does it become a business
well so for me i always do the three
bucket test so um a week has 168 hours
in it so split that up into three you
got 56 56 56
if you sleep eight hours a night like
you're supposed to sleep eight hours a
night that's 56 hours eight hours a
night seven days a week 56 hours
a normal full-time job is about 56 hours
maybe it's contracted for 40 but you
have commuting time you're maybe staying
late you might be doing work at home
like i was so 56 those two buckets pay
for justify and create your third bucket
that is your side hustle bucket it's
your fun buckets or anything you want
bucket you can binge watch netflix you
can go to the gym or you can write a
book in my case
for all those years i was at walmart and
in my books it was always in that bucket
only when leslie and i got married and
we had kids and that third bucket
quickly became bedtime bath time dinner
then i was like uh oh my work bucket
which is 56 hours of walmart has to be
one or two has to be walmart or writing
and so then i made the decision which
would i be prouder with on my deathbed
and if it fails what could i go back to
what can i go back to two tests deathbed
test and the plan b test
the writing pass both tests at that time
i'd be prouder of it and if it failed i
could hopefully knock on doors and get
job again so then i did it
so it still took me a lot of years and
looking back i probably should have left
earlier but for me keeping those things
going at the same time was healthy for
two reasons number one
it create it created risk ticking in the
other
so having a full-time job at walmart
meant my blog didn't need to have ads i
could write about whatever i wanted i
wasn't counting on it and the the blog
and the books being successful
means i could speak truth to power at
work i could ask the ceo a question and
when that happens in corporate offices
you get promoted
so risk taking was created in the other
by having something to fall back on in
both if someone wanted to follow your
path
and and be
a non-fiction writer turn to thought
leader through speaking gigs
get paid for writing books give her
speaking consulting coaching all the
stuff that you do
at what at what point whether it's
timeline or number of books sold can it
become a feasible
career oh well that depends on your cost
of living and it depends on the type of
lifestyle you want
so if you live in an urban center and
you want to buy a home
and you want to have children like
that's a different thing than like uh
someone who's single living in a cheap
apartment in the middle of nowhere right
who's like maybe making small amounts of
money on ad revenue so let's say i want
to make 100 000 a year yeah oh okay so i
can tell you all the numbers how they
work so basically um the average
hardcover makes three dollars and the
average paperback makes one dollar
okay
so for me today zoom up to today
um
that that's just a way so books are
largely a small industry so most people
that are writers can't make enough to
quit their job start with that
most people who are writers cannot make
enough money to quit their jobs to
because also a writers like the salaries
like this like it's
like unless you have another book or
another book right
so then you think well how do i
monetize that more if i want to and for
most thought leaders they do a number of
different things
speaking you mentioned is one very
common thing so i think the value of
live is increasing in the world i think
content is free and it's everywhere and
everyone can watch anyone's ted talks
you can watch myself by southwest talk
my google talk on my ted talk for free
so why would you have me at your
conference because the value of live is
increasing that also plays into that
thing about book signing i said staying
late going early shaking every hand
that's worth a lot of money because no
one else does it right so that's one
thing but also the value lives
increasing because it's harder and
harder to get a uniform group of people
going one direction
right because everyone's so scattered so
that's valuable so speaking's one
another thing is and i've never done
this monetizing your properties
branding deals influencer marketing ads
on your website like that's huge a lot
of people that are thought leaders that
have email lists have ads in their email
list or sponsors in their email list i
do not i've chosen not to do that i'm
against ads
i have a podcast my podcast is called
three books i'm looking for the 1000
most formative books in the world it's a
great way to keep the conversation going
about my books but also i've chosen no
ads no sponsors no promotions no
interruptions none of that because i
don't like them that's actually the only
reason i don't have ads because i'm
selling books so i'm i don't need it and
i'm giving speeches so i don't need it
and i don't want it and that's choice i
make but some people might say well i
don't want to do the hustle and i don't
want to do speaking i don't want to do
traveling but i'm going to monetize
my
podcast and for them i say congrats like
i have no judgment it's just a totally
different model
i'm just
anti-advertising because i feel dirty
about ads
that's because i that's just random for
me all right i love it yeah yeah that's
just my thing i don't have ads on my
blogs on my podcasts i'm nothing i got
no ads but
in exchange i'm also
doing other things that other people
wouldn't do probably so yeah you got to
do what's right for you in line with
your integrity in line with your
principles that makes you feel
happy at the end of the day and live
an awesome life
i love it man
dude thank you so much for all the
energy and attention and value in this
10-part series for people who want to
find you dive deeper into your world
maybe buy the book like what do you what
do you want people watching what do you
want as a next step for them to take
even though you don't like ads let's let
people want to dive deeper into your
world okay my world all centers on one
website which is just neil dot blog
n-e-i-l dot b-l-o-g
dot blog
that's it it's got links to all the
stuff i do i love it man thank you for
coming on dude thanks for having me it
was a lot of fun yeah to learn how to
build a million dollar coaching business
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there whoa our life
advisor you're taking somebody's life in
your hands
and so i think it's very very important
to
become educated in what it means to
coach somebody in their life